आई थिंक वी आर लाइव
नाउ लेट मी चेक
वंस चलो एक बार चेक कर लेते हैं लाइव
नॉट हेलो एवरीवन हेलो हेलो एवरी
बडी सो यस वी आर लाइव
नाउ आईम ऑडिबल एंड विजिबल गाइस प्लीज लेट
मी नो प्लीज मुझे बता दीजिए सभी लोग एम
ऑडिबल एंड
विजिबल प्लीज लेट मी नो प्लीज एवरी
बडी आवाज जा रही है मेरी
सबको ओके ओके सो लेट एवरी बडी जॉइन जल्दी
से सबको आ जाने देते हैं ऑडियो एंड वीडियो
सब कुछ सही है ना कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है ना
लेट मी चेक
वंस ठीक है सभी लोग आ गए यस यस गुड इवनिंग
एवरी बडी गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गुड
इवनिंग सबको गुड इवनिंग
भाई
ओके चलिए चलिए
बढ़िया चलिए बढ़िया धन्यवाद धन्यवाद
धन्यवाद वो टेस्ट क्रेडेंशियल थे प
जैसा कि मुझे डाउट लगा था मुझे टेस्ट
एनवायरमेंट के टेस्ट क्रैडेंशियल्स थे
वो यस सो गुड इवनिंग
एवरीबॉडी फ्री कोर्स एंड एज बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज हम करने वाले हैं बहुत ही
शानदार चीज करने वाले हैं आपको
बस कंसंट्रेट करना है आज के सेशन में एंड
यू विल गेट टू नो अ लॉट ऑफ थिंग्स राइट
मैं यहां पर मोबाइल प चैट देखता हूं आपका
एंड इसलिए मैंने मोबाइल भी मेरा साइड में
ओपन र हता है तो मैं उसको भी मॉनिटर करता
रहता हूं तो
चलिए गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग सबको गुड
इवनिंग
बढ़िया काफी कम लोग आए अभी तो फिलहाल बट
ठीक है अभी और लोग आ जाएंगे चलिए हां तो
मैं स्टार्ट तो करता हूं बट उसके पहले मैं
आपको एक चीज बता देता हूं बहुत ही सिंपल
सा पहले उसको देख लीजिए जरा सा यहां पर आई
थिंक ओके एवरीथिंग गुड
हां मैं एक चीज नोटिस कर रहा हूं गाइस आप
लोग लाइक आप लोग का
एंड सर आई वाज वर्किंग इन टारगेट एंड
फेचिंग जेएस फाइल्स एंड सीक्रेट्स यूजिंग
सीक्रेट फाइंडर टूल द टूल शोज मी अ लॉट ऑफ
इंफॉर्मेशन आल्सो हिरोक एपीआई की बट आई एम
नॉट श्यर अबाउट दैट श्यर नहीं हो कोई
टेंशन नहीं है रिपोर्ट कर दो देखो आप श्यर
नहीं हो कोई टेंशन आपको नहीं लेनी है अगर
आपको लग रहा है कुछ पता नहीं है कुछ क्या
है क्या नहीं है तो भी आप रिपोर्ट करो
सामने वाला क्या करेगा डुप्लीकेट नॉट
एप्लीकेबल या तो एक्सेप्ट करेगा सिंपल अगर
आपको नहीं पता है तो अदर वाइज अगर आपको
पता है आगे के प्रोसेसेस के बारे में समझ
में आ रहा है तो इंपैक्ट दिखाने की कोशिश
करो आपके रिपोर्ट में जो भी वनबिल या बग
रिपोर्ट करते हो अगर आप इंपैक्ट दिखाओगे
तो यू विल गेट द बाउंट इतना मैं श्यर के
साथ शर्ली बोल सकता
हूं आपके ग्रुप डिस्कशन में कोई संदीप
बार-बार भेज रहा है ठीक है मैं देखूंगा
चलिए स्टार्ट करने से पहले मैं आप लोगों
को एक चीज समझा देता हूं बता देता हूं
आपकी नेक्स्ट क्लास यानी क्लास 15 तभी
होगी जब आप लोग क्लास 14 तक कंप्लीट कर
चुके होंगे एंड आपको जो टास्क्स दिए गए
हैं या आपका जो भी लाइक व्हाट एवर योर अ
काइंड ऑफ आपका जो इसको बोलते हैं ना कि जो
भी अ प्रोग्रेस है उसको आप
15th क्लास
linkedin.com / d सीधा नक् सर्च कीजिएगा
आपका आ जाएगा @ लगा के एंड यहां पे यह
मेरी प्रोफाइल है जो कि linkedin.com
टेक्निकल नेविगेटर पे मैं रिचे बल हूं ठीक
है तो आप क्या कीजिएगा सिंपली हमें टैग
कीजिएगा ताकि मुझे पता आपकी क्या
प्रोग्रेस है इसके बाद ही आपकी 15th क्लास
आएगी आप में से जितने लोग भी देख रहे हैं
आई वुड रिक्वेस्ट यू कि अगर आप यह काम
करते हैं तो आपके लिए बेनिफिशियल है ठीक
है ना बहुत जो भी चीजें आप कर रहे हैं
उसको आप लाइक एक तरह से रिपोर्ट की तैयार
कीजिए स्क्रीनशॉट्स हो या
में बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें होने वाली है
और आज आपने टाइटल देखा होगा एडब्ल्यू एस
तो आपको क्या लगा है कि एडब्ल्यू एस की हम
क्या सेटअप करेंगे वो तो पहले ही कर चुके
हैं आज हम जानेंगे एडब्ल्यू एस
एक्सप्लोरिंग एंड
एंड टारगेटिंग द टारगेटिंग
द
लेस
लीक्ड बकेट्स ठीक है लीक्ड बकेट्स और मिस
क फिगरड मिस कन फिगर्स
मिस
कॉन्फिडेंस कन्फर्ट्स क्या इससे क्या मतलब
आपका इससे मतलब क्या है मैं आपको समझाता
हूं देखो एडब्ल्यू एस बकेट्स जो होते हैं
काफी सारे कंपनीज के द्वारा यूज किए जाते
हैं एडब्ल्यू ए s3 बकेट्स अब ये क्या होते
हैं पहले आप इसको समझिए पहले देन आप आगे
की चीजें जो है आपको समझ में और ज्यादा
आएंगी तो मैं क्या करता हूं मैं अपने पहले
एडस अकाउंट लॉग इन कर लेता
हूं यहां मैं कंसोल में साइन इन कर लेता
हूं
देखिए यहां मैं चलता हूं यहां आपको s3
सर्विस पर चलनी है क्योंकि s3 s3 सर्विस
क्या है amazon2 सर्विस जो है
जैसे कोई भी क्लाउड सर्विस में आप अपने
फाइल्स को स्टोर करते हैं
google3 सर्विस है s3 बकेट्स इसको बोलते
हैं बकेट्स बाल्टी उसमें आप चीजों को
स्टोर करते हैं
दैट्ची उसके पास एक फ्लेक्सिबल क्लाउड
सर्विस के लिस्ट है जिसमें कि s3 बकेट्स
भी एक लिस्ट में से है जहां पे आपको
स्टोरेज की फैसिलिटी मिलती है यानी कि आप
क्लाउड में amazon2 में मिलियंस ऑफ
मिलियंस ऑफ ट्रिलियंस ऑफ डाटा को स्टोर कर
लोगे कोई बिना किसी स्टोरेज की टेंशन के
बहुत सारे स्टोरेज स्पेस है उनके पास आप
उनका यूज कर सकते हो अब मान लो लेट्स सपोज
आप क्या कर रहे हो s3 बकेट में क्या कर
रहे हो स्टोर डाटा कर रहे हो ठीक है अब
आपका बकेट आपने बकेट के ऊपर कोई पॉलिसी
डिफाइन की आपने कुछ एक्सेस कीज लगा दिए
आपने बकेट को सिक्योर कर दिया तब तो आपका
बकेट सिक्योर है बिल्कुल सही है बट बाय
चांस किसी मिस कन्फेशन की वजह से किसी
किसी भी वजह से बाय चांस आप उसको
सिक्योरिटी नहीं दे पाए या सिक्योर नहीं
रख पा रहे बकेट को तो वह पब्लिकली
एक्सेसिबल हो जाता है और कोई भी उस बकेट
को एक्सेस कर पाएगा तो उस बकेट में जो भी
चीजें होंगी व्हाट एवर जैसे सेंसिटिव
डाटा क्रेडिट कार्ड डिटेल
ल्स
पासवर्ड टोकेंस
कोड्स और भी मेनी अदर सेंसिटिव
डाटा तो यह सारी डाटा जो होंगी वह क्या हो
जाएंगी यह लीक हो जाएंगी आपकी एंड
पब्लिकली एक्सेसिबल हो जाएंगी और कोई भी
उस डाटा को एक्सेस कर पाएगा ये पव प2
कैटेगरी में आ जाता
है लाइक यू कैन इट एट लाइक सिक्योरिटी मिस
कॉन्फिन में सेंसिटिव डाटा एक्सप्लोजन के
अंदर में आप इसको डाल सकते हैं इस वनबिल
को ठीक है अब चलिए देखिए इसमें कैसे ये
चीजें होती है पहले मैं आपको दिखा देता
हूं ये s3 का मेरा ये s3 का पोर्टल है
यहां पे आपको क्रिएट बकेट पे क्लिक जाना
होता है सिंपली और यहां पे आप कोई सा भी
एक बकेट क्रिएट कर सकते हैं जैसे बकेट नेम
दे दीजिए ये रीजन सेलेक्ट कर लीजिए यहां
पे उसके बाद ये कुछ ओनरशिप का अ मेंशन है
यहां पे डि एसीएल का एक्सेस कंट्रोल लिस्ट
का बाय डिफॉल्ट डिसेबल होती है इनेबल कर
सकते हैं एंड एंड ये एक इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है
ब्लॉक ऑल पब्लिक एक्सेस बाय डिफॉल्ट तो ये
टिक होता है ब्लॉक ऑल पब्लिक एक्सेस कई
सारी मिस कन्फेशन की वजह से कई कई रीजंस
की वजह से कभी-कभी ये अनटिक अगर हो जाता
है बाय चांस किसी भी अ कंपनी की या किसी
भी पर्टिकुलर बकेट की तो ये पब्लिकली
एक्सेसिबल हो जाता है एंड एक्सपोज्ड ऑन
इंटरनेट हो जाता है और उसको कोई भी एक्सेस
कर सकता है उस पर्टिकुलर बकेट को ये मैं
आपको दिखाऊंगा किस तरीके से एक्सेस किया
जाता है कैसे यू कैन आल्सो डू एंड उसके
बाद ये सारी कुछ ऑप्शंस हैं ये करके आप
क्रिएट बकेट कर दीजिएगा उसके बाद बकेट जब
क्रिएट हो जाती है तो बकेट के अंदर में आप
कुछ भी अपलोड कर सकते हैं जो भी फाइल्स आप
लोग अपलोड करनी है व्हाट एवर यू वांट टू
अपलोड यू कैन अपलोड एंड
दैट्ची जिए सिंपल जैसे मैं एक बकेट देता
हूं माय टेस्ट अ बकेट मैंने ये बकेट लिख
दिया यहां पे ब्लॉक ऑल पब्लिक एक्सेस को
मैं डिसेबल कर देता हूं फिलहाल के लिए एंड
यहां पे नीचे आ जाता हूं मैं यहां पे एंड
क्रिएट बकेट पे क्लिक कर देता हूं जैसे ही
मैं क्रिएट बकेट पे क्लिक करूंगा यहां पे
आ रहा है ओके अनोले मुझे करना पड़ेगा यहां
पे आके क्रिएट बटन क्रिएट बटन क्लिक कर
देते हैं माय टेस्ट बकेट ऑलरेडी लिया हुआ
है तो मैं यहां पे 9958 ये मैं एक नाम लगा
देता हूं यूनिक बनाने के लिए क्रिएट बकेट
पे क्लिक कर देता
हूं अब देखिए यहां पे माय क्रिएट बकेट अब
बकेट तो मेरा क्रिएट हो चुका है माय अ ये
जो बकेट है अब यहां पे मैं व्यू डिटेल्स
पे आता हूं तो ये माय बकेट 9958 में मैं आ
चुका हूं अब यहां पे मैं नॉर्मली जैसे
फाइल अपलोड वगैरह करते हैं ना किसी भी
क्लाउड स्टोरेज में वही अपलोड करूंगा यहां
पे तो यहां मैं कोई भी चीज ड फाइल फोल्डर
करके ऐड कर सकता हूं जैसे मैं ड फाइल कर
देता हूं य पर मैं कोई एक फाइल अपलोड कर
देता हूं जैसे
कि यह वाली फाइल डाल देते हैं या कुछ भी
डाल देते हैं
चलो चलो मान लो यह वाला कर देते हैं ठीक
है डीसी जसपी सर्टिफिकेट यह वाली
सर्टिफिकेट वाली फाइल जो है मैं इसमें एक
इमेज फाइल है इसको डाल देता हूं या कोई और
फाइल देख लेते हैं व्ट एवर वी कैन कोई सा
भी हम कर सकते हैं मैं डेस्कटॉप से कोई
फाइल उठा लेता हूं
अ चलिए एड s3 बकेट डॉक्स ये डॉक्स है तो
ये डॉक्स को मैं उठा लेता हूं डॉक्स वाली
फाइल को मैंने अपलोड कर दिया ठीक है तो
यहां पे ये सेलेक्ट कर लिया एंड यहां पे
बस
दैट्ची अपलोड हो गई इस पे आप क्लिक करेंगे
ब अ इस वाले पे तो आपको इसकी डिटेल मिल
जाएगी एंड इस डिटेल के अंदर में आपको इसकी
पूरी यूआरएल मिल जाएगी जब ये यूआरएल आप
देखेंगे तो कुछ इस तरीके का यूआरएल आपको
देखने को मिलेगा मैं आपको दिखाता हूं किस
तरीके का यूआरएल होता है ये रहा मैं एंटर
करूंगा यहां पे अभी आ रहा है एक्सेस
डिनाइड क्योंकि वहां पे कुछ पॉलिसीज हैं
वो हमने वहां पे अ बेसिकली वो पॉलिसीज बाय
डिफॉल्ट लगी हुई होती है इसलिए आपको यहां
पे एक्सेस डिनाइड आ रहा है ठीक है यहां पे
परमिश पे आ जाएंगे यहां पे यहां पे
अलग-अलग परमिश आप देख सकते हैं एवरीवन
पब्लिक एक्सेस में क्या है किसी को कोई
परमिशन नहीं है ओनर को रीड एंड राइट का
परमिशन है यहां पे ठीक है अब यहां पे चलिए
एक चीज देखते हैं एक चीज चीज समझते हैं अब
यहां पे इसका यूआरएल किस तरह का दिखता है
देखिए कुछ इस तरह का यूआरएल दिखता है जब
आप बकेट का यूआरएल देखते हैं चलिए यहां पे
मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं
अ पहले समझते हैं देन इसका प्रैक्टिकल
देखेंगे हंट करेंगे डायरेक्टली अब इस
यूआरएल में क्या होता है पहले एचटीटीपीएस
प्रोटोकॉल जो आपका है वो होता है उसके बाद
बकेट का नाम होता है जैसे मैंने दिया था
माय टेस्ट बकेट 9958 ये बकेट का नाम देया
उसके बाद ये प्रोटोकॉल लाइक s3 कौन सी
सर्विस आप यूज़ कर रहे डब्ल्यू की तो s3
को यूज़ कर रहे हैं s3 स्टोरेज के लिए यूज
होता है आपका एडब्ल्यू का बहुत सारा
सर्विस होता है ठीक है तो यहां पे आपको
दिखा
होगा एडब्ल्यू एस के जब होम पेज प आप
आएंगे यहां पे तो आपको बहुत सारी सर्विसेस
दिखेंगी जैसे s3 है स2 है इलास्टिक कंटेनर
है यहां पे क्लाउड फ्रंट है यह सब
सर्विसेस है वैसे ही s3 एक सर्विस है यहां
पे ठीक है तो अब यहां पे ये s3 उस सर्विस
का नाम हो गया और ये एी साउथ वन ये अन
एडब्ल्यू का रीजन हो गया जिस रीजन में में
आप ये काम कर रहे ऑपरेट कर रहे वो रीजन हो
गया उसके बाद amazonaws.com ये इसका फाइनल
जो है आपकी पूरी की पूरी ये फाइनल ये
यूआरएल बनके इस तरीके से आ जाती है एंड
कोई पर्टिकुलर फाइल जो है वो उसका लास्ट
में उसका पाथ जो है वो आपको दिख जाता है
ठीक है भैया तो
[संगीत]
दैट्ची ठीक है आरसी तो यहां पे ये फाइल हो
गया ठीक है यह फाइल आपके पास आ गई टेस्ट
कड सरसी टेक
ओके चलिए यह तो आपको समझ में आ गया अब
देखिए अब देखिए क्या होता है अब हमें जब
इसको एक्सेस करना होगा तो हम कैसे एक्सेस
करेंगे पहले थोड़ा सा इस चीज को समझ लेते
हैं ठीक है इस चीज को हम पहले क्या करेंगे
समझेंगे चलिए अब यहां पे आते हैं एंड यहां
पे आने के बाद मैं इसको बैक कर देता हूं
यहां पे यहां पे अब जैसे मान लो मेरे इस
पर्टिकुलर बकेट को कोई एक्सेस कर कर ले
रहा है पब्लिकली तो दैट वुड बी अ वनबिल या
मिस
कन्फर्ट यह मुझे ही सिर्फ एक्सेस होना
चाहिए बाकी किसी को एक्सेस नहीं होना
चाहिए बस इस चीज का आपको ध्यान रखना है
यही होती है यह लेबिलिटी अगर आप किसी
पर्टिकुलर s3 बकेट को एक्सेस कर पा रहे
हैं जो आपकी नहीं है किसी और कंपनी की है
और उसके अंदर बहुत सारी डाटा हो सकती है
मुझे आप खुद बताइए ना क्या-क्या डाटा हो
सकती है चलिए आप ही लोग बताइए मुझे एक
स्टोरेज डिवाइस के अंदर जैसे आप हार्ड
डिस्क है या कोई क्लाउड स्टो
[संगीत]
एलियट थैंक यू ब्रदर थैंक यू सो मच
कॉन्फिन नेम पासवर्ड इंपॉर्टेंट
डॉक्यूमेंट ग्रेट बहुत बढ़िया एकदम सही
क्लाइंट इंफॉर्मेशन
पासवर्ड यूजर फाइल पब्लिक इंफो यूजर
इंफॉर्मेशन
बैकअप्स डेटाबेस बिल्कुल सही
यूजर पासवर्ड क्लाइंट डिटेल्स ठीक
है एडमिन यूजर नेम वर्कर्स इंफॉर्मेशन
हां बिल्कुल सही है आप आप सबका बिल्कुल
सही है हर एक चीज जनरली हो सकती है हर एक
चीज हो सकती है जो आप सोच सकते वो हो सकती
है क्योंकि स्टोरेज है यार कुछ भी डाल
सकता है कोई कंपनी अब चलिए अब यही हमें
मिस कंफर्ड बकेट्स को खोजना है हमारा यही
काम है ट्स इट हमारा पूरे इंटरनेट से जो
मिस कन्फर्ट्स हैं पूरे इंटरनेट से
उनको क्या करना है खोजना है ट्स इट चलिए
तो अब खोजने वाला काम हम शुरू करते हैं
कैसे खोजना है कैसे क्या करना है वह भी हम
देखते हैं सारी चीजें समझते हैं सबसे
पहले मैं अपनी मशीन ऑन कर लेता हूं मैं
अपना पेंटेस्ट बॉक्स जो है हमारा डिजिटल
ओसन के ऊपर में वो ऑन कर लेता हूं अगर
आपको भी डिजिटल ओसन क्लाउड यूज करना है
क्लाउड में बग बाउंट करनी है एंड
मशीन यूज करना है क्लाउड में नट या डेयन
या कोई भी मशीन जैसे मैं अभी नट यूज कर
रहा हूं तो आप डिजिटल ओसन का क्लाउड
सर्विस यूज कर सकते हैं बहुत ही अफोर्डेबल
होता है एंड स्टार्टिंग में आपको $200 का
ये जो क्रेडिट पॉइंट है मिल जाएगा अगर आप
इसी वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन में डिजिटल
ओसन का मेरा रेफरल लिंक्स है वहां से जाके
अगर आप साइन अप करते हैं तो यू विल गेट
$200 बोनस जो क्रेडिट है 60 दिनों के लिए
दो महीनों के लिए ठीक है दो महीने तब तक
आप इतना कुछ करेंगे सही से कर रहे हैं तो
आपको बाउंट भी आ सकती है एंड फिर आप तो
खरीद भी सकते हैं कोई बड़ी बात नहीं है
ठीक है ठीक है और बहुत सस्ता है ये तो
यहां पर मेरा पेंटेस्ट बॉक्स है मैं इसको
बस सिंपली क्या कर लेता हूं स्टार्ट कर
लेता हूं ऑन कर लेता
हूं
चलिए कैन यू मेक द वीडियो ऑन एक्सप्लोइट
डेवलपमेंट मैं एक्सप्लोइट डेवलपमेंट में
गया नहीं हूं अभी बट अगर मैं गया एंड गया
तो मैं शली वीडियो बनाऊंगा 110
पर डीजे आज डीजे ने 200 का सुपर चैट किया
थैंक यू सो मच डीजे ब्रदर
एंड सपोर्ट डि फोनिक्स बिल्कुल धन्यवाद डि
फोनिक्स को सपोर्ट करने के लिए बहुत-बहुत
धन्यवाद चलिए तो यहां पर मैंने आईपी कॉपी
कर ली एंड मैं अगेन मोबा एक्सटम ही यूज
करूंगा जैसा कि मैंने पहले यूज किया था इट
इज अ वेरी गुड टूल तो आप मोबा एक्सटम फॉर
विंडोज यूज कर सकते हैं बढ़िया है यह
बढ़िया है मतलब यह एंड यहां पर मैं
एग्जीक्यूट कर देता हूं एंड लेट मी
कनेक्ट सो आई होप मशीन ऑन हो चुकी होगी
मेरे ख्याल से हो चुकी होगी हां तो यह हो
गया डन तो इसको मैं जूम इन कर लेता हूं
थोड़ा सा एंड हमारा मशीन गुड टू गो है एंड
एवरीथिंग
इ ओके नाउ चलिए तो डिशन मशीन प हम आ चुके
मशीन हमारा काम कर रहा है अब अब क्या करना
है गाइस चलिए लेट्स सी व्हाट वी कैन डू
नाउ अब हमें हंट करना है हमें हंट करना है
एडब्ल्यू एस मिस कन्फर्ट्स के लिए जहां भी
मिले वहां से उठा लो जहां से भी मिले वहां
से उठा लो तो सबसे पहले मैं आपको इसके लिए
ऑटोमेशन वाली स्ट्रेटजी बताऊंगा टूल्स का
यूज करके एंड फिर मैं आपको मैनुअल वाले
बताऊंगा क्योंकि मैनुअल जो है ज्यादा
इंटरेस्टिंग है इसमें ऑटोमेशन वाला थोड़ा
सा लाइक वो
है मतलब क कई बार आपको फॉल्स पॉजिटिव भी
मिल जाएंगे बट स्टिल ऑटोमेशन आप यूज कर
सकते हैं टाइम बचाने के लिए बट मैनुअल इज
द बेस्ट वे जस्ट लाइक गट बकन ठीक है चलिए
अब मैं यहां
पे अब मैं यहां पर देखता हूं डीजे 500
सुपर चैट कर दे
गुड न्यूज दे दो अपना सीटीएफ प्लेटफॉर्म
ला रहे हैं हां जी हम अपना खुद का सीटी
प्लेटफॉर्म ला रहे हैं बट जब तक लच नहीं
होगा तब तक मैं कुछ अभी बात नहीं करूंगा
उसपे जैसे ही लच होता है वी विल टॉक ऑन
दैट
राइट चलिए तो अब सबसे पहले हमें क्या करना
है हमें एक टूल को इंस्टॉल करना है s3
बकेट्स को एक्सप्लोर करने के लिए s3 बकेट
से आप कैसे इंटरेक्ट कर पाएंगे उसके लिए
यू नीड अ टूल उस टूल के बिना आपने कर
पाएंगे तो कौन सा वो टूल है वो है
एडब्ल्यू एस सीएल आई एडब्ल्यू एस सीएल आई
टूल जो है यह इंस्टॉल ऐसे सर्च कर लेना
आपको एंड उसके
बाद यह यह वाली लिंक है कमांड लाइन
इंटरफेस एड्स सील आई इस पर आ जाइएगा
एडब्ल्यू एस के नीचे आ जाइएगा यहां नीचे आ
जाइएगा नीचे आ जाइएगा नीचे आ जाइएगा नीचे
आ जाइएगा नीचे आ जाइएगा नीचे आ जाइएगा
कहीं कुछ नहीं है नीचे नीचे यह
रहा टूल्स प आ जाइए एक
बार नहीं यह वाली लिंक नहीं है फिर यह वा
वाली लिंक है ये वाली आई थिंक सो लेट्स
ओपन
इट यस इस वाली लिंक पे आ जाइएगा पहला जो
लिंक है आपका यहां पे आ जाइएगा तो इंस्टॉल
करने का एड स का ऑप्शन आएगा
एमएसआई फाइल यहां पे डाउनलोड होनी स्टार्ट
हो जाएगी मैं यहां पे फिलहाल कैंसिल कर
देता हूं एंड उसके बाद आप जैसे ही इंस्टॉल
कर लेंगे आपका एडब सीआई काम करना शुरू कर
देगा एंड आप उसको विंडोज में चेक कर सकते
हैं कैसे चेक करेंगे अपना टर्मिनल ओपन
कीजिए एडब्ल्यू न i वर्जन एंड एंटर कीजिए
आपको यहां पे अगर दिखा देता है वर्जन
एडब्ल्यू सीएआई तो यू आर गुड टू गो एंड
एडब्ल्यू लिख के आप अगर एंटर करते हैं तो
आपको एडब्ल्यू सीएआई जो है वो अ ओपन हो
जाएगी एंड आपको इसकी हेल्प फाइल भी है जो
है आप देख सकते हैं जो भी आपको को देखना
है यू कैन डू व्हाट एवर यू वांट टू डू ठीक
है तो एक तो विंडोज में आपने ऐसे कर लिया
अब बात करते हैं
टेस्ट बकेट 9958 यह बकेट बनाया अब मुझे
इससे इंटरेक्ट करना है तो हाउ आई विल
इंटरेक्ट विद दिस बकेट लेट्स सी मुझे क्या
करना है एडब्ल्यू एस लिखना है उसके बाद
मुझे एड्स की कौन सी सर्विस यूज करनी है
ए3 मैं थोड़ा सा और बड़ा कर देता
हूं ए3 अब मुझे क्या करना है एलस लिस्ट
करनी है क्या लिस्ट करनी है बकेट को लिस्ट
करनी है तो ए3 कॉलन स्ल स्ल और बकेट का
नाम तो मेरा बकेट क्या दिया माय
टेस्ट बकेट 9958 यह मेरा बकेट है अब मैं
यहां पे एंटर करूंगा और एंटर कर रहा हूं
तो देखिए क्या आता है अ लेट्स
सी चलिए जैसे ही मैंने एंटर किया यह आ रहा
है द एडब्ल्यू एस एक्सेस की यू प्रोवाइडेड
डज नॉट एजिस्ट इन आवर रिकॉर्ड्स यानी कि
एड्स एक्सेस कीन के रिकॉर्ड में नहीं है
अब भाई कैसा एक्सेस की अब चलिए अब मुझे
अगर यह एरर नहीं लानी है तो मैं क्या
करूंगा यहां पे हान न नो साइन रिक्वेस्ट
यह लगा दूंगा एक फ्लैग और एंटर करूंगा अब
देखते हैं क्या होता है अब देखिए जैसे
मैंने नो साइन रिक्वेस्ट किया यहां पर
एक्सेस डिनाइड आया क्यों क्योंकि हमारी यह
जो बकेट है यह पब्लिक के लिए एक्सेसिबल
नहीं है इट इज नॉट एक्सेसिबल फॉर पब्लिक
सिंपल सा फंडा है क्यों भैया क्योंकि जब
हम इसको कॉपी करके और ऐसे डायरेक्टली ओपन
करेंगे तो यह देखिए यहां पर क्या आ रहा है
एक्सेस डिनाइड क्या आ रहा है एक्सेस
डिनाइड सिंपल सा फंड है एक्सेस डिनाइड आहा
है अब देखिए यहां पे अब मैं माय टेस्ट
बकेट में चलता हूं यहां पे बकेट्स में
चलते हैं यहां पे माय टेस्ट बकेट में चलते
हैं यहां पे यह वाली माय टेस्ट बकेट को
यहां प कर ओपन कर लेते हैं यहां
प्रॉपर्टीज पे चलते हैं एक बार एंड यहां
प्रॉपर्टीज प जाएंगे आप नीचे आएंगे नीचे
आएंगे नीचे आएंगे नीचे आएंगे यहां पे नीचे
आ जाइए नीचे आ जाइए नीचे आ जाइए अ
एवरीथिंग परमिश कहां गई परमिश ये रहा
परमिश में आप आ गए यहां पे ये देखिए यहां
पे ब्लॉक ऑल पब्लिक एक्सेस हमने क्या किया
सब कुछ डिसेबल करके रखा है पब्लिक एक्सेस
को कोई पब्लिक एक्सेस कंफिट नहीं किया है
यहां पे यहां पे नीचे आ जाते हैं नीचे आ
जाते हैं यहां पे नीचे आ जाते हैं यहां पे
एंड यहां पे ऑब्जेक्ट ओनरशिप जो है एडिट
करते हैं यहां पे एसीएल डिसेबल्ड है ठीक
है कोई बात नहीं एसीएल हमने डिसेबल करके
रखा हुआ है नीचे आ जाते हैं यहां पे एंड
यहां पे इंडिविजुअल अ जो है वो सारी चीजें
जो है अनब्लॉक्ड ही है सारी चीजें यहां पे
बकेट पॉलिसीज वगैरह होते हैं जो आप मेंशन
कर सकते हैं इफ यू वांट नहीं चाहते तो आप
छोड़ दीजिए कोई दिक्कत नहीं है यहां पे
एंड उसके बाद यहां पे देखिए दिस बकेट हैज
द बकेट ओनर इन फोर्स सेटिंग अप्लाइड फॉर
ऑब्जेक्ट ओनरशिप ठीक है अब यह देखो वन
बकेट ओनर इन फोर्स इ अप्लाइड यूज बकेट
पॉलिसी टू कंट्रोल एक्सेस ठीक है अब इसमें
बकेट ओनरशिप जो है ना इफोर्स किया गया है
ऑब्जेक्ट पे तो ऑब्जेक्ट कहां पे है भैया
हमारे ऑब्जेक्ट प चलते हैं यहां पे यह
वाली हमारी ऑब्जेक्ट है तो इस पर चल जाते
हैं अब इसम आते हैं तो यहां जब आएंगे यहां
पे तो ये देखिए
वेयर इट इज परमिशन परमिशन ये रहा परमिशन
में आ जाते हैं यहां पे एक बार परमिश में
आ जाते हैं एंड यहां
पे बकेट ओनरशिप यहां पर आ जाते हैं यहां
पे बकेट ओनरशिप इफोर्स ठीक है अब यहां पर
मान लो एसीएल अगर आप इनेबल कर देते हैं
मान लो बाय चांस ठीक है यहां पे तो बकेट
ओनरशिप प्रेफर्ड है यहां प एसी इनेबल में
मैं एक्नॉलेज करता हूं और मैं यहां पे
ऑब्जेक्ट राइटर कर देता हूं यहां पे एंड
यहां पे ये चीज कर देते हैं ठीक है यहां
पे सेव कर देते हैं एक बार चलिए ये सेव हो
गया हमारा अब यहां पे नीचे की तरफ आते हैं
यहां पे एंड यहां पे एक्सेस कंट्रोल लिस्ट
आ रही है यहां पे अब एडिट करते हैं अब
एडिट करके यहां पे हम क्या करेंगे एवरीवन
पब्लिक एक्सेस को रीड का यानी कि लिस्ट
करने का हम एंड रीड का एंड लिस्ट का ये
दोनों परमिशन हम दे सकते हैं ठीक है दोनों
परमिशन हम दे दिया बाकी किसी को नहीं दिया
हमने ऑथेंटिकेटेड यूजर ग्रुप का भी दे
सकते हैं तो चलिए इसको भी हम लिस्ट और रीड
कर देते हैं ये दो ये ये हमने कर दिया
यहां पे अप्लाई किया और यहां पे सेव
चेंजेज कर दिया चलिए ये तो हमने सेव
चेंजेज कर दी सारा कुछ हो गया अब हम यहां
पर क्या करते हैं एक बार फिर से सेम कमांड
में करके और एंटर करके कोशिश करते हैं
ट्राई करते हैं लिस्ट करने का और देखिए
जैसे ही हमने लिस्ट किया यहां पे हमें
पहले एरर आ रहा था अब हम वापस से जब हम इस
कमांड को चलाएंगे तो हमारी जो बेसिकली
बकेट है उसके अंदर की जो फाइल है वो लिस्ट
होके आ जाएगी एवरीवन कैन सी द फाइल ए3 बड
t एक यह आपने देखा सब लोगों
ने एवरीवन कैन सी दैट वी लिस्टेड द बकेट्स
सबको दिख रहा है
है बताइए मुझे चैट
में हमने एसीएल इनेबल करके और एसीएल में
हमने एक सिक्योरिटी परमिशन जो है क्या करी
पब्लिक के लिए इनेबल कर दिया ठीक
है हां लैपटॉप चाहिए भाई बिना लैपटॉप को
तो क्या होगा एवरीवन कैन सी प्लीज
बताइए
ओके ओके थैंक यू चलो बढ़िया अच्छा आ गया
तो आपको आपको यहां पे ठीक
है ठीक है अब यहां पे हमारी बकेट यह वाली
बकेट जो है ये आ चुकी है अब मैं एलएस करता
हूं मेरी करंट जो मेरे पास करंट
डायरेक्टरी है अभी यहां पे रूट डायरेक्टरी
उसमें कहीं प भी आपको ये सारी फाइल्स है
यहां पे ठीक है
अब अब मैंने बस यह किया और मेरी बकेट जो
है यहां पे आ चुकी है ठीक है अब मुझे
चाहिए मान लो आई वांट कि मैं इस बकेट
को इस बकेट इस बकेट के जो बकेट है जो यहां
पर बेसिकली इसको मैं चाहता हूं कि कॉपी कर
लू इसको मैं कॉपी करूं कहां पर कॉपी करूं
मेरे पास कॉपी कर लू तो यहां पर सीपी
कमांड आप लगा देंगे तो आपका कॉपी हो जाएगा
एड्स ए3 सीपी ठीक है भैया सीपी क्या करना
है सीपी कौन सी करनी है माय टेस्ट बकेट से
माय टेस्ट बकेट जो है ये करनी है लेकिन
क्या सीपी करना है एडब्ल्यू
ए s3 बकेट ड
tx3 यहां पे आपको पूरा पाथ देना पड़ेगा एड
ए
s3
बकेट डॉक्स डटी एक्टी एंड यहां पे मैं
कहां पे कॉपी कर देता हूं लेट्स कॉपी ट
रूट रूट स् एड्ड एक्सटी लेटस सी हैपनिंग
और
नॉट ओके ओके ओके बकेट यहां
पर एडब एस
एस3 बकेट डक्ड
एक्सटी इसको यह कॉमा की तरह ले रहा है तो
एक काम करते हैं
यहां
पर यह वाली या तो हम फाइल नेम को थोड़ा सा
चेंज करेंगे ब लेटस
सी ओके लेट्स पुट इट एन डबल कोट लेट्स पुट
इट इन डबल
कोट एड्स
एस3
बकेट लेट्स पुट इट इन डबल
कोट ड एक्स देखते इसको मे भी ये कंसीडर
करें चलिए यहां पे एक काम करते हैं सी एल
ए आर क्लियर एंड लेट्स ट्राई
टू ट्राई टू चेंज हियर लेट्स गो टू द
ऑब्जेक्ट्स लेट्स गो हियर क्लिक ऑन
हियर एंड एंड एंड एंड यह वाली फाइल यहां
पे
ऑब्जेक्ट यहां पर चलते हैं माय टेस्ट पके
में इस बकेट को एक बार क्लिक करते हैं
यहां से एक बार डिलीट करते हैं एंड यहां
से
परमानेंटली डिलीट एंड
डिलीट ठीक
है ओके एंड यहां पर क्लोज कर देते हैं
अपलोड लेट्स अपलोड हियर लेट्स ड अ फाइल
हियर एंड लेट्स ड अ बकेट जेस सीक्रेट्स
चलिए जे सीक्रेट्स डटी एक्सटी इसको न इसको
डाल देते हैं एक बार जेस सीक्रेट्स में
एंड इसको अपलोड कर देते हैं ठीक
है चलिए अपलोड हो गई यहां पे इसको क्लिक
करते हैं यहां
पे इसको क्लोज कर लेते हैं लेट्स क्लिक ऑन
इट लेट्स सी द परमिशन कौन सा है एडिट कर
देते हैं इसको अगेन रीड रीड वाला परमिशन
रीड वाला परमिशन दे ऑथेंटिकेटेड यूजर का
भी दे देते हैं रीड एंड रीड एंड इसको हम
अंडरस्टैंड कर देते हैं इसको हम सेव चेंज
कर देते हैं ठीक है सोट्स इट यहां पर वापस
से व विल ट्राई
टू
कैप्चर देखते
हैं लेट्स
सी ठीक है लेट्स
सी ् यहां पर आ रही है यह चीज अब हम क्या
करते
हैं कॉपी कमांड लगाते हैं यहां पे एंड नाउ
वी विल यूज आप लोग वो देख लीजिएगा डबल कोट
सिंगल कोट वाला फिलहाल तो बट यहां पर करते
जेएस सीक्रेट्स डटी एक्सटी एंड देन रूट
एड्स इसको करते हैं जेस सीक्रेट्स जे एस
सीक्रेट जे एस
[संगीत]
सीक्रेट्स लेट्स
सी यस डन तो यहां पे क्या हो रहा है
कंप्लीटेड 288 बाइट्स यहां पे एंड यहां पे
ये कंप्लीट हो चुका है यहां से आपने कॉपी
कर लिया अब मैं एलएस करूंगा तो यहां पे
मुझे दिख जाएगा जेएस सीक्रेट्स नाम से एक
फाइल देखो
j मैं इसको अगर व्यू करना चाहता हूं तो
इसको मैं ऐसे करके यहां से कैट करके यहां
पे इसके अंदर के कंटेंट को व्यू कर लूंगा
सिंपल सा फंडा है जो यहां पे कंटेंट है तो
व्हाट आई डिड सिंपल मैंने क्या किया मैंने
एक सिंपल एडब्ल्यू से यहां से लिस्ट किया
बकेट को और उसको क्या किया इस पर्टिकुलर
कमांड से ये कमांड देख
लीजिए कॉपी कर लिया
यह कमांड से हमने कॉपी कर लिया यह आप लोग
कमांड देख लीजिए सर इतना अच्छा पढ़ा रहे
हो बार-बार सुपर चैट करने अरे भाई डीजे
रहने दो यार ट्स इट काफी सुपर चैट कर दिया
तुमने ठीक है चलिए तो यह चीज हो गई यह
हमने क्या किया इसको डाउनलोड कर लिया इसको
सिंपल क्या किया हमने इसको कॉपी कर लिया
एंड डाउनलोड कर लि अब मान लो मुझे लेट्स
सपोज मुझे कोई फाइल आप आपको कोई फाइल बकेट
में मान लो डालना है वो कैसे करोगे तो
एलएस करो यहां पे यहां से कोई फाइल
उठाओ जैसे मैं क्या करता हूं रड 25t इसको
मुझे मान लो उधर डालने का है तो मैं क्या
करूंगा
एडब s3 यूज़ कर रहा हूं मैं सीप अब मैं
यहां पे पहले फाइल डाल दूंगा
रैपिड रैपिड 25t
xt5
txt.gz भाई यार सर हमें ये बकेट कहां से
मिल सकती है सब डोमेन फाइंड कहां बता रहा
हूं मैं आपको कहां से मिलेगी वही तो मैं
बता रहा हूं वही तो अभी बताऊंगा मैं एड
s3p
सो होप फुली इट शुड अपलोड दिस फाइल ऐसा
होना चाहिए देख लेते हैं अपलोड फेल्ड क्या
आ रहा
है एक्सेस
डिनाइड ओके अपलोड इज फेल्ड अपलोड वाला
एक्सेस यहां पर हमें डिनाइड आ रहा है वाई
बिकॉज बिकॉज ऑफ द परमिशन राइट ओके ओनली
रीड का परमिशन है इसलिए यह हमें नाई आ रहा
है हमने इसको बेसिकली क्या है पब्लिक के
लिए यहां पर राइट का परमिशन यहां पर नहीं
है राइट
इसलिए हमें यह अपलोड का यहां पर नहीं हो
पा रहा है बट ठीक है कोई बात नहीं कोई
टेंशन नहीं है हम यहां पर बकेट ओनर जो है
ना वो कर सकते हैं इस चीज को अब बकेट ओनर
का मतलब क्या होता है गा मैं आपको बताता
हूं बकेट ओनर का मतलब क्या हो जाता है
बकेट ओनर का मतलब है आप अपने एडब्ल्यू एस
अकाउंट से लॉग इन करके तब वह काम कर रहे
हो लॉग इन कैसे करोगे जैसे देखो जैसे
यूजर्स के थ्रू लॉगिन आप करोगे कैसे करोगे
देखो जैसे आपको क्या करना है एडब्ल्यू
सर्विस जाना है एंड यहां
पे आईएएम पे क्लिक करना है आई
जहां पर आपके यूजर्स
क्रिएटेड्रॉअर्नेविगेटर आते हो गिट हब
रेकन करते हो ना गिट रेकन से भी तुम फाइंड
कर सकते होड्स तो यहां पर मान लो तुमने
सर्च किया क्या सर्च किया कोई भी एक कंपनी
को टारगेट कर रहे हो मान लो लेट्स सपोज
paytm.com को टारगेट कर रहे हो एंड यहां
पे तुमने सर्च
किया कोई भी एक कौन सा कीवर्ड सर्च करोगे
एडब्ल्यू एस
कन्फर हां जी एडब्ल्यू एस एक्सेस की आईडी
एडब्ल्यू एस सीक्रेट एक्सेस की तो एक्सेस
की आईडी
एक्सेस की आईडी ये वाली सर्च करेंगे
एक्सेस की आईडी ठीक है ये वाला टे सर्च कर
लिया हमने उसके बाद एक्सेस की आईडी बस
सर्च कर लो
दैट्ची paytm.com का लेट्स सी कुछ मिलता
है कि नहीं कुछ मिलता है अगर कोड यहां पे
मिलता है हमें कोड कोड में चलते हैं
paytm.com में यहां पे देखते हैं यहां कुछ
है कि नहीं एक्सेस की आईडी में में कुछ
यहां पे एक्सेस की आईडी
[संगीत]
रिजल्ट्स मिल रहे हैं लास्ट पे ठीक है
इसको देख लेते हैं इसमें कुछ है क्या
एडब्ल्यू एस
का कंट्रोल एफ एडब्ल्यू एस नहीं कुछ भी
नहीं है इसमें देख लेते
हैं
अ
नथिंग लेट्स सी लेट्स फाइंड
समथिंग आप लोगों को एडब्ल्यू एस की एक्सेस
की और सीक्रेट की ऐसे जो मिलती है ना उसी
की बात हो रही है यहां पे ठीक है द सेम
थिंग सेम चीजें यहां पे सेम चीजें बात हो
रही है
सेम वी आर ट्राइट फाइंड तो उसका फॉर्मेट
क्या होता है मैं आपको बस वही दिखाना चाह
रहा था फॉर्मेट होता है एडब्ल्यू एस
एक्सेस की आईडी और एडब्ल्यू सीक्रेट की
एक्सेस की ये दोनों अगर मिल जाते हैं तो
इसका मतलब आप लॉगइन कर सकते हो सिंपल सा
फंड है ठीक है तो अब मैं क्या करूंगा यहां
पे मैं यहां पे कैसे ये amazonaws.com
ऐड यूजर टू ग्रुप कॉपी परमिशन अटैच तो मैं
यहां कर रहा हूं ऐड यूजर टू ग्रुप ठीक है
नेक्स्ट पे क्लिक करता हूं यहां पे
नेक्स्ट पे क्लिक करने के बाद यहां पे
नीचे आएंगे टेस्ट यूजर आ गया यहां पे
क्रिएट यूजर यहां पे क्या आ रहा है कंसोल
पासवर्ड यहां पे आ रहा है यहां पे
रिक्वायर्ड पासवर्ड रिसेट नो कुछ भी नहीं
है यहां पे यहां पे क्रिएट यूजर पे क्लिक
करते हैं यहां पे ठीक है यहां पे क्रिएट
यूजर हो गया टेस्ट यूजर ठीक है अब मैं
यहां पे टेस्ट यूजर पे एक बार चल चलता हूं
यहां पे जब टेस्ट यूजर पे आएंगे यहां पे
तो इस तरीके से यहां पे ऑप्शंस होंगे यहां
पे आप सिक्योरिटी क्रैडेंशियल्स में आएंगे
तो इस तरीके से सिक्योरिटी क्रैडेंशियल्स
जो है यहां पे इसमें आपको एक्सेस कीज का
यहां पे एक ऑप्शन दिखेगा तो क्रिएट एक्सेस
की पे क्लिक करेंगे तो यहां पे आप किस लिए
एक्सेस की आप यूज करना चाहते हैं कमांड
इंटरफेस या लोकल कोड या किस लिए तो मैं
सीएआई के लिए यूज करना चाहता हूं मान
लीजिए तो मैंने सीआई किया यहां पे एंड
यहां पे टिक कर दिया और नेक्स्ट पे क्लिक
कर दिया नेक्स्ट पे क्लिक करते ही यहां पे
आ रहा है डिस्क्रिप्शन टैग वैल्यू कोई भी
टैग वैल्यू कर दीजिए यहां पे तो मैं टेस्ट
मेंशन कर देता हूं एंड क्रिएट एक्सेस की
पे क्लिक कर देता हूं मैं जैसे ही क्रिएट
एक्सेस पे क्लिक करूंगा गाइस मेरा एक्सेस
की यहां पे क्रिएट हो चुका रहेगा समझ में
आया मैं ये डिलीट कर दूंगा वो टेंशन नहीं
है वो आप समझ लीजिए मैं ये डिलीट कर दूंगा
लेकिन स्टिल मैंने ये क्या किया एक्सेस
किया अब मुझे अगर लॉग इन करना है इससे डब्
सी से तो कैसे होता है यह लॉगइन चलिए व्ट
आई विल डू मैं यहां पर एक कमांड टाइप
करूंगा एडब्ल्यू एस एंड देन यहां पर टाइप
करूंगा कन्फर एडब्ल्यू एस कन्फर एंटर
करूंगा जैसे ही मैं एंटर करूंगा य मुझसे
एड्स एक्सेस की आईडी मांगेगा तो मैं यहां
पर एड्स एक्सेस की आईडी ये रही इसको मैं
कॉपी कर लूंगा एंड यहां पर मैं इसको
पेस्ट कर दूंगा और मैं एंटर कर दूंगा अब
ये एक्सेस की मांगेगा तो मैं क्या करूंगा
यहां से एक्सेस की कॉपी कर लूंगा एंड यहां
पे मैं पेस्ट मारूंगा और यहां पे एंटर कर
दूंगा डिफॉल्ट रीजन कुछ नहीं नन नन करके
एंटर कर दूंगा एंड
दैट्ची बस इतना करना है अब जैसे ही मैंने
इतना किया अब मुझे बकेट का तो माय टेस्ट
बकेट माय टेस्ट बकेट 9958 यह करना है और
मैं एंटर करूंगा जैसे ही मैं एंटर करूंगा
अभी देखिए ऑटोमेटिक बिना नो साइन नो साइन
रिक्वेस्ट के जो हमने पहले जो हम पहले
क्या देते थे हान न नो फिर हाई फन साइन
ऐसे रिक्वेस्ट यह नहीं देना पड़ा ऑटोमेटिक
ये लिस्ट हो चुका है ठीक है अब मान लो
मुझे क्या करना
है मान लो व्ट आई नीड टू डू मुझे क्या
करना है इसमें एक बार आप कॉपी करके देखनी
है लेट्स सपोज परमिशन अगर यह अलाउड है कि
नहीं है नहीं होगा तो आप परमिशन सेट कर
लेंगे कॉपी हो जाएगा कॉपी करने के लिए
लोकल फाइल क्या है सीपी देना है लोकल फाइल
जो भी कॉपी करनी है
रड
txt.gz कर दी और एंटर कर देंगे अगर आपके
पास सफिशिएंट परमिशन है तो ये अपलोड हो
जाएगी नहीं तो डिनाइड हो जाएगी सिंपल सा
चीज है तो यहां पे एप्रोप्रियेट
के अंदर में इस तरीके से आप कॉपी कर लेंगे
और वहां पे अकाउंट में वो अपलोड जो है वो
पर्टिकुलर जो है चीज अपलोड हो जाएगी
क्योंकि अभी हमारा उस ग्रुप में नहीं है
यूजर इसलिए ये अप्लाई नहीं हो पा रहा है
मतलब अपलोड नहीं हो पा रहा है क्योंकि
उसको सफिशिएंट परमिशन नहीं है तो इस तरीके
से आप यूजर्स भी बनाते हैं फिलहाल में
यूजर को अ मैंने बस टेस्ट पर्पस के लिए
बनाया था तो मैं इसको सिंपली क्या कर देता
हूं डिलीट कर देता हूं टेस्ट यूजर को ताकि
कोई दिक्कत ना हो तो टेस्ट
यूजर मैंने इसको डिलीट कर
दिया चलिए डिलीट हो गई चलिए बढ़िया ट्स इट
समझ में आ गया इतना समझ में आ रहा है सबको
अब चलिए देखते हैं आपको यह बकेट्स कहां से
मिलेंगे यह बकेट्स आप कहां से खोज के
लाएंगे आप कहां से इसको निकाल के लाएंगे
कहां से ढूंढ के लाएंगे सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट
चीज ये है तो सबसे पहले हमने क्या किया
हमने क्या किया भैया हमने पहले क्या
किया अंडरस्टूड
व्हाट इज एडब्ल्यू एस बकेट यह आपको पता चल
गया बकेट क्या होता है दूसरा इंस्टॉल
एडब्ल्यू एस सील आई टू एक्सेस और लिस्ट
बकेट्स
ठीक है अब हम तीसरा करने वाले हैं यूजिंग
टूल्स
टू फाइंड लीक्ड बकेट्स तो अब हम टूल्स का
यूज करने वाले हैं तो सबसे इसमें
इंटरेस्टिंग टूल जो है इसमें एक एक टूल जो
है वह है लेजी
s3 एंड दूसरा जो टूल है हमारा वह है s3
स्कैनर सबसे बढ़िया टूल वर्किंग एंड बहुत
बढ़िया इन दोनों को यूज कीजिए बाकी टूल
यूज करने की आपको जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी ना के
बराबर पड़ेगी तो सबसे पहले हम देखते हैं
लेजी s3 इस टूल को देखते हैं व्हाट इट कैन
डू एंड हाउ वी कैन यूटिलाइज दिस टूल
एक्चुअली चलिए तो यह टूल
है लेजी s3 गिट अप सर्च करेंगे दिस टूल इज
फ्रॉम नहम सेक द जीनियस इन बग बाउंटीज आप
सबको पता होगा शायद एंड यहां पे लेजी ए3
में क्या है अ रूबी स्क्रिप्ट टू ब्रूट
फोर्स एडब ए3 बकेट्स यूजिंग डिफरेंट
परम्यूटेशन बस ट्स इट एक रूबी स्क्रिप्ट
है और कुछ भी नहीं है और यहां पर आपको
कॉमन बकेट प्रीफिक्स डटी एकटी फाइल दी हुई
है मतलब क्या है देखिए ओपन
कीए यह जो प्रीफिक्स है ये इसी प्रीफिक्स
को एक पर्टिकुलर कंपनी के लिए जिसकी आप
बकेट्स खोजें उसको इन प्रीफिक्स को यूज कर
कर के बकेट्स फाइंड करने की कोशिश करेगा
एक पर्टिकुलर टारगेट के लिए ठीक है मतलब
बकेट्स जो इन सबसे स्टार्ट हो
एडमिनिस्ट्रेशन एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर एड्स अल्फा
एंड्राइड एंगुलर एन सिबल एपीआई एक्सेट्रा
एक्सेट्रा अब ये ये जो कीवर्ड्स है आपके
ये आपके सब डोमेन वाले कीवर्ड्स भी हो
सकते हैं क्योंकि सब डोमेंस भी कुछ इसी
तरीके के होते हैं लगभग लगभग तो आप सब
डोमस वाले भी कीवर्ड्स यूज करके यहां पे
अप्लाई कर सकते सकते हैं आप इसका भी यूज
कर सकते हैं वो आपकी मर्जी है तोब इसको
यूज करने के लिए क्या करना पड़ेगा सिंपल
सा फंडा है क्या करना है गिट क्लोन करना
है बस और तो कुछ नहीं करना है तो सिंपल
यहां से गिट क्लोन कर
लीजिएगा आपके वीपीएस के अंदर यहां पे गिट
क्लोन करके एंड इसको पेस्ट मार दीजिएगा
जैसे ही एंटर कीजिएगा यह क्लोन हो जाएगा
मेरा ऑलरेडी यहां प क्लोन है मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं लेजी s3 बस ठीक है तो मैं
सीडी लेजी s3 इसके अंदर में चला जाऊंगा
एंड यहां जाने के बाद एलएस करोगे आप तो
यहां पर आपको ले s 3rb दिखेगी यह रूबी में
लिखी हुई एक स्क्रिप्ट है तो आपके पास
रूबी इंस्टॉल होना चाहिए तो उसके लिए एट
इंस्टॉल्ड इंस्टॉल एंड रूबी क्लिक करेंगे
तो आपका रूबी जो है इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा मेरा
ऑलरेडी इंस्टॉल है तो जरूरत नहीं पड़ रही
है ठीक
है
ओके दूसरे क्लाउड सर्विस का भी यूज कर
सकते हैं डिजिटल ओसन का भी आप फाइंड कर
सकते हैं सबका फाइंड कर सकते हैं मैं
बताऊंगा अभी बहुत कुछ तो यहां पे आपका
इंस्टॉल हो चुका है अब अब इसको यूज करने
के लिए क्या करना है रूबी उसके बाद लेजी
s3 रूबी एंड हाइन एच कर दीजिएगा तो इसकी
हेल्प फाइल आ जाएगी या फिर जो भी आ रहा है
कोई बात नहीं यहां पे रूबी लेज s3 रूबी और
उसके बाद क्या करना है आपको क्या चीजें
प्रोवाइड करनी है आपको जो टारगेट है वो
टारगेट प्रोवाइड करना है अब मुझे मान लो
कोई भी टारगेट मुझे देना है तो मैं कौन सा
टारगेट दे रहा हूं कोई सा भी टारगेट चूज
कर लो भाई तो लेट्स चूज टारगेट
एज बताओ आप लोग टारगेट बताओ बताओ कौन सा
टारगेट चूज करें कोई पॉपुलर टारगेट बताना
ऐसे बताना कि बिल्कुल जिसको कोई जानता ही
ना उसका एडब्ल्यू ऐसा टारगेट होना चाहिए
जो एड्स का यूज कर रही हो ऐसा नहीं कि
एड्स यूज ही ना करो आपको बकेट मिल जाएगा
ना भाई जो बड़ी कंपनीज है जो बड़ी
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर जिनके पास बहुत सारे
स्टोरेज चाहिए होते हैं वह सब एडब्ल्यू
जनरली एड्स या डिजिटल ओसन या अजर
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट एजर यूज करते हैं तो
बताओ लेट मी
नो बताइए आप ही लोग
बताइए
टेस्ला सभी लोग बताइए प्लीज बाकी लोग
रिप्लाई
कीजिए टेस्ला काफी लोग बोल रहे हैं चलिए
टेस्ला ले लेते हैं काफी लोग टेस्ला बोल
रहे हैं तो टेस्ला ये हमने क्या किया
टेस्ला ट्स इट ये हमने कर दिया और हम अब
एंटर करेंगे अब जैसे ही एंटर करेंगे तो
आपके पास आएगा जनरेट वर्डलिस्ट फ्रॉम फाइल
9013 आइटम्स 9013 आइटम्स जो हैं वर्डलिस्ट
से यहां पे इन्होंने एक बनाया परम्यूटेशन
अब ये बकेट्स फाइंड करेंगे जैसे एक फाउंड
बकेट टेस्ला ये आपको मिल गया एक बकेट
लेकिन ये बकेट 403 है समझ में आ रहा है
403 मतलब एक्सेसिबल नहीं है 200 आएगा तो
एक्सेसिबल है याद रखिएगा 200 तो ये
एक्सेसिबल नहीं है ऑब् वियस तो कोई बात
नहीं कोई कोई टेंशन नहीं है इसको इसको ऐसे
ही होने देते हैं यह थोड़ा आपको वेट करना
पड़ेगा और इसको इसको सर्च करना पड़ेगा यह
सर्च करेगा फिर आपके पास लाकर लाकर आपको
देगा रिजल्ट जो भी रिजल्ट्स है राइट ट्स
इट लेट्स
सी मैं यहां पर न्यू टैब एक बार ओपन कर
लेता हूं
[संगीत]
एंड न्यू टैब में भी चलो इसको अभी फिलहाल
तो रहने देते
हैं
तो यहां पे मैं रूबी
एंड लेजी ए3 में चलते हैं एंड रूबी लेज ए3
रूबी एंड यहां पे हम दे देते हैं एक
टारगेट हमारा एंड दिस टाइम वी आर गोइंग टू
गिव
[संगीत]
टारगेट पेटीएम पेटीएम दे
दे यबर चलो यबर दे देते हैं यबर दे देते
हैं र देते र र र तो हम यहां पे u दे दिया
एंड यहां पे इसको मिला है u का बट यह 403
ही मिला है अब मान लो कोई ब बकेट मिल रहा
है आपको जैसे अभी तो 403 है तो इसको
एक्सेस कैसे करते हैं सिंपल इसको कॉपी
कीजिए ब्राउजर में जाइए एंड यहां सर्च
कीजिए यहां लिखिए
tesla.svs
3 amazonaws.com s3 के बाद आप रीजन भी
डिफाइन कर सकते हैं जैसे मान लो ए साउथ वन
ऐसे रीजन है तो आप डैश देके रीजन भी असाइन
कर सकते हैं अदर वाइज आप बिना रीजन के
डायरेक्टली s3s कर सकते हैं ऐसे कर सकते
हैं तो यहां पे आप जैसे ही आप एक्सेस करते
हैं ये एक्सेस डिनाइड आ रहा है क्योंकि
403 वहां पे ऑलरेडी आ चुका था आपको पता ही
है तो हमने यहां पे भी कर दिया हमने यहां
पे भी u को भी चला दिया है एंड यहां पे
देख रहे हैं लेट्स अ सी इफ वी कैन गेट सम
बकेट्स हियर अ सम 200 बकेट्स वी कैन गेट
तो यह आपको थोड़ा टाइम लेगा लाइक आपको
थोड़ा टाइम ना पड़ेगा यहां पे एंड यह
बेसिकली स्कैनिंग कर रहा है ऑलरेडी जितने
भी वर्डलिस्ट इसने जनरेट किए हैं इट इज
स्कैनिंग एंड इट इज डूइंग इट्स वर्क ठीक
है तो चलिए यहां पे यूबर वाला साइड वाला
चल रहा है इसको चलने देते हैं ये वाले को
हम रोक देते हैं ताकि हम इसमें दूसरा काम
कर सके ठीक है चलिए ये तो आपने एक टूल देख
लिया कौन सा टूल है भैया ये आपने देखा
लेजी s3 इसको इसी तरीके से यूज करना है और
कुछ भी नहीं करना है बहुत सिंपल सा फंडा
है इसी तरीके से आपको यूज कर लेना है ये
आपको समझ में आ गया होगा चलिए अब मैं आपको
दिखाता हूं गाइस कि अब दूसरा टूल कौन सा
है जिसको आप यूज कर सकते हैं एंड दैट टूल
इज नोन एज
स्कनर उसको चलने देते हैं साइड में
क्योंकि ज्यादा टाइम लेगा ना इसलिए ए3
स्कैनर चलते
हैं यह
रहा मजा आ रहा है ना सबको शेयरिंग कर रहे
हो कि नहीं कर रहे हो भाई शेयर कर दो लाइक
ठोका है कि नहीं ठोका है लाइट नहीं ठोका
क्या समने अरे यार लाइट ठोका करो यार कभी
तो मजा आता है चलिए अब ए3 स्कनर को
इंस्टॉल कैसे करना है भैया बहुत आसान है
देखो ए3 स्कैनर में क्या फायदा है अ टूल
टू फाइंड ओपन ए3 बकेट्स इन एडब्ल्यू और
अदर क्लाउड प्रोवाइडर्स एडब्ल्यू का आप
ओपन बकेट फाइंड कर सकते हो डिजिटल ओसस के
आप फाइंड कर सकते हो ड्रीम होस्ट के
जीसीपी
google3 स्कैनिंग है सपोर्ट मेनी बिल्ट इन
s3 स्टोरेज प्रोवाइडर्स स्कैन ऑल बकेट
परमिशन टू फाइंड मिस कॉन्फिन सेव रिजल्ट्स
टू पोस्ट गेड डेटाबेस में आप कर सकते हैं
कनेक्ट टू रेबिट एमक फॉर ऑटोमेटेड
स्कैनिंग एंड स्केल एंड डॉकर सपोर्ट भी है
इसमें सबसे बढ़िया ये है ठीक है नीचे आते
हैं नीचे आते हैं यहां पे अब इसको इंस्टॉल
करने के बहुत सारे तरीके हैं भैया होम ब्र
मैक में सीधा ब्रू इंस्टॉल ए स्कनर कालीले
में ए इंस्टॉल एथ स्कैनर पैट ए में एप
इंस्टॉल ए स्कैनर ब्लैक आर्क में इस तरीके
से पैकमैन डॉकर में इस तरीके से ए विंगेट
हम यहां पे गो का इंस्टॉल गो का यूज़ करने
वाले हैं क्योंकि हम डेब एन ओ यूज़ कर रहे
हैं तो हम सीधा गो वाला यह कमांड यूज़ कर
लेंगे गो का आपका पाथ सेट होना चाहिए याद
रखिएगा गो का पाथ कहां पे सेट होता है ये
आपको मैंने पहले ही बताया था यहां
पे ट मैं यहां पे डॉट अ बैश आरसी बैश आरसी
में आपका यहां पे नीचे में कुछ इस तरीके
का यहां पे गो का पाथ आपको दिख रहा होगा
ये वाली आपको दिख रही होगी ये पाथ इस
तरीके से आपको यहां पे ये एंट्री होनी
चाहिए पहले गो रूट गो का रूट डायरेक्टरी
जो है गो का रूट लोकेशन वो बताते हैं तो
यूएसआर लिब गो के अंदर गो उसके बाद गो का
पाथ बताते हैं तो होम के अंदर गो और उसके
बाद जो पाथ है वो बता देते हैं भैया कि ये
पाथ है हमारा दोनों पाथ जो है एक गो रूट
का और एक आपका जो गो पाथ है ठीक है तो ये
आपका आ चुका है अब यहां पे आपने जो कॉपी
किया है उसको पेस्ट मार दीजिए जो कमांड
कॉपी किया है सॉरी ये क्या हो
गया यहां से इसको कॉपी किया आपने एंड यहां
पे पेस्ट कर
दीजिए इंस्टॉलेशन स्टार्ट हो जाएगा तो
मेरा ऑलरेडी ये इंस्टॉल्ड है s3 स्कैनर तो
मैं इसको ऐसे इंस्टॉल नहीं कर रहा हूं और
यहां देखिए यहां पे यहां पे कुछ बकेट्स
मिले हैं u के बट यह सब 403 है 200 वाला
कुछ बकेट नहीं मिला अभी तक तो इसको चलने
देंगे कोई टेंशन नहीं है इसको चलने देंगे
आप चला के छोड़ दीजिए इसको कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग स्टफ मिल सकते हैं आपको
पर्टिकुलर कंपनीज के ठीक है बहुत मजा आता
है जब आपको 200 200 मिलेगा अब यहां पे
मुझे s3 स्कैनर चलाना है तो मैं क्या
करूंगा s3 स्कैनर चलाने के लिए देखिए मैं
यहां पे इसको जूम इन करके फुल स्क्रीन कर
देता हूं
एंड हां अब मैं क्या करूंगा ए3 स्कैनर इस
तरह से करूंगा हान इसकी हेल्प फाइल देखने
के लिए तो आपकी इसकी हेल्प फाइल यह ओपन
होक आ गई पूरी हेल्प फाइल यहां पे तो एक
बकेट को स्कैन करना है अगर सिर्फ एक सिंगल
बकेट को तो हाइन
बकेट इस तरीके से दे दीजिएगा तो कैसे
स्कैन करेंगे ए3 स्कैनर
हाइन बकेट और बकेट का नाम देना चाहते हैं
तो मेरा जैसे माय टेस्ट बकेट 995 था ना
9958 ठीक है तो मैंने क्या किया मा बकेट
9958 यह किया और एंटर कर दिया जैसे ही
मैंने एंटर किया यहां पे मेरे पास रिजल्ट
आ गया इंफो एजिस्ट ये एजिस्ट करता है माय
टेस्ट बकेट एपी साउथ वन रीजन का है ये एंड
यहां पे ऑल यूजर क्या कर सकते हैं रीड कर
सकते
हैं ऑल यूजर को रीड का परमिशन है और कोई
परमिशन नहीं है तो आप सिर्फ देख सकते हैं
रीड कर सकते हैं या फाइल को कॉपी कर सकते
हैं इसमें कोई डाटा डाल नहीं सकते डिलीट
नहीं कर सकते ये सब काम आप राइट वाला नहीं
कर सकते हैं ठीक है तो ये इस तरीके से आप
देख सकते हैं दूसरा एक इसमें और चेंज कर
दीजिए इनमेट बकेट ऑब्जेक्ट्स अगर आपको
बकेट के ऑब्जेक्ट्स को इनमेट करवाना है तो
हाइन इनमेट लगा दीजिए
नमरे और एंटर कर देंगे अब एंटर करेंगे तो
आपको यहां पे पहले सिर्फ यह क्या बता रहा
था एग्जिट करता है बकेट का नाम रीजन और
ऑथराइज यूजर कौन-कौन से हैं ऑल यूजर्स को
क्या परमिशन अब यहां पे ये एक बता रहा है
क्या कि वन ऑब्जेक्ट्स भी है इसमें 220
288 बाइट का अब ये ऑब्जेक्ट्स के बारे में
बताएगा कि एक ऑब्जेक्ट भी है भैया इसके
अंदर में ठीक है तो आप इस तरीके से कर
सकते हैं अब मान लो मुझे क्या करना है मान
लो लेट्स सपोज मुझे क्या करना है कोई
पर्टिकुलर क्लाउड प्रोवाइडर को स्कैन करना
है एडब्ल्यू एस बाय डिफॉल्ट इसमें है इस
टूल को यूज कीजिएगा तो यहां पे देखिए यहां
पे ये इसके हेल्प फाइल में लिखा हुआ है
डिफॉल्ट एडब्ल्यू अगर आपको डिजिटल ओसन का
फाइंड करना है जीसीपी का करना है ड्रीम
होस्ट का करना है तो आप वो मेंशन कर सकते
हैं हान प्रोवाइडर फ्लैग के साथ ठीक है तो
दैट्ची वो
देखिए ए3 स्कैनर चलते हैं हान पर चलते हैं
यहां पर एंटर कर देते हैं अब यहां पर मुझे
मान लो इसका
जो तरीका है इस टूल को चलाने का वह क्या
है चलिए देखते हैं अब एक बकेट फाइल मेरे
पास फाइल्स ऑफ बकेट नेम्स टू चेक लिस्ट ऑफ
बकेट है अगर आपके पास मान लो आपके पास
लिस्ट ऑफ बकेट है जिसको कि आप इनमेट करना
चाहते हो तो यह बकेट फाइल वाला कीवर्ड लगा
सकते हो बकेट फ वाला ठीक है अब मेरे पास
एक बकेट की फाइल की लिस्ट है कौन सी लिस्ट
है भैया बकेट वाली कौन सी लिस्ट है देखिए
एलएस
करूंगा यह वाली बकेट लिस्ट है मेरे पास
कहां गई कहां
गई लेजी में थी ना यार चलो सीडी लेजी s3
में चलते हैं एलएस करते हैं एंड यहां पे
ये देखो कॉमन बकेट प्रीफिक्सेस डटी एक्टी
ये वाला भी यूज कर सकते हैं या बकेट की
फाइल्स भी डाउनलोड कर सकते हैं कहीं से
अगर आपको चाहिए तो आप डाउनलोड कर लीजिए
कहीं से खोज लेते हैं कोई बात नहीं
एडब्ल्यू एस
बकेट एडब्ल्यू एस
बकेट डॉक्स डॉक्स नहीं करेंगे बकेट
प्रीफिक्सेस
ठीक है तो यहां पे चलते
हैं गिट
हब यह रही ये
रही
चलो
ओके इसमें कुछ है बकेट की लिस्ट बकेट की
प्रीफिक्सेस नहीं है हम वैसे हमारे पास
मिल जाएंगे बट अभी हम देख लेते हैं यहां
से कहीं कुछ मिल जाए
तो अगर कुछ लिस्ट मिल जाती है तो यहां से
डॉट टेस्ट इसमें तो नहीं मिलेगा आपको यह
वाली प्रीफिक्सेस यहां पे है बहुत सारी तो
यहां पर क्या कर देते हैं एडब ए s3 बकेट
बकेट वर्ड
लिस्ट वर्ड लिस्ट कर लेते हैं वर्ड लिस्ट
सर्च कर लेते हैं ठीक है तो यह रहा बकेट
वर्ड लिस्ट बकेट वर्ड लिस्ट वर्ड लिस्ट
बहुत पावरफुल
कीवर्ड है यार तो ये वाली वर्ड लिस्ट में
चल जाते हैं ए3 कॉमन बकेट नेम्स तो इसको
ओपन करते हैं तो यह बकेट कॉमन बकेट नेम
आपको यहां पे दिख रहा है ठीक है ये देखिए
ये कॉमन बकेट नेम देख लीजिए कितने हैं
2374 है यहां पे ठीक है यहां आ जाते हैं
ये कितने हैं 2000 377 यह वाली सेम है ये
सेम अच्छा ये सेम ही है ना हम सेम ही है
तो यहां पे आपको लिस्ट आ गई बढ़िया है आप
कोई सा भी डाउनलोड कर सकते हैं जैसे मेरे
पास यही है ना तो list.txt ये वाली है ठीक
है तो मैं इसको ही ओपन यूज कर लेता हूं एड
बकेट के लिए चलिए तो मैं इसको रॉ पे क्लिक
करता हूं मैं इसको डाउनलोड कर लेता हूं तो
मैंने यहां पे कॉपी किया एंड लेट्स
डाउनलोड इट विद इन
आवर दिस
वन तो मैं क्या करता हूं यहां पे डब्लू
गेट कर लेता हूं एंड यहां पे मैं इसको
पेस्ट कर देता
हूं कर दिया यहां पे एलस करेंगे अब यहां
पे मुझे मिल मिल चुकी है यहां पे लिस्ट
डटी एक्टी यह बकेट के लिस्ट है कट
list.txt देखेंगे तो यहां पे आपको लिस्ट
जो है बकेट्स की जो भी बकेट्स वाली है वह
सारी यहां पे मिल गई है चलिए बढ़िया अब हम
इसी को यूज करने वाले हैं किसम यूज करने
वाले हैं s3 स्कैनर में यूज करने वाले हैं
तो s3 स्कनर हान h अब इसको कैसे यूज करना
है
देखिए कमांड लगाना है s3 स्कैनर
उसके बाद हाइन बकेट फाइल
हाइन बकेट फाइल यह डाल दीजिएगा उसके बाद
बकेट फाइल का डाल दीजिए तो मेरा क्या है
क्या था लिस्ट डटी एक्सटी में था बकेट का
पूरा उसके बाद यहां पे डेटाबेस में सेव
करना है तो डीवी नहीं तो छोड़ दीजिए कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है हाइन इनमेट आपको ऑप्शन लगा
देना है तो मैं यहां पे हाइन इन मेरेट आप
में से कितने लोग कर रहे हैं भाई बताइए
मुझे जरा हाउ मेनी ऑफ यू आर डूइंग
व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग ओके ठीक है आप इधर ध्यान दीजिए
प्लीज इधर ध्यान दीजिए प्लीज इधर ध्यान
दीजिए आप लोग तो यहां पर आपको यह कमांड
चलानी है ठीक है
आपको यह वाली कमांड चलानी यह कमांड चला के
और आपको क्या करना है यहां पे सिंपल फंडा
में एंटर कर देना है अब हम एंटर करेंगे तो
देखिए क्या होता है जैसे ही हमने एंटर
किया यह देखिए यह उस बकेट के अंदर से जो
भी हमने कीवर्ड्स डाले थे वो कीवर्ड्स को
लेके अब यह स्टार्ट किया इसने बकेट
हंटिंग मिस कन्फर्ट्स को हंट करना यह
स्टार्ट कर रहा है और यहां लास्ट में आप
देख रहे होंगे बहुत सारी चीजें आ रही है
मैं आपको दिखाता हूं देखो जैसे एक बकेट
इसने फाइंड किया मार्केटिंग वाला इसमें
99.2 जीब की डाटा
है न 211 ऑब्जेक्ट्स में 211 ऑब्जेक्ट्स
में 99.2 जीब की डाटा है सोचो यह कितना
इंटरेस्टिंग हो सकता है अब हम इसको एक्सेस
करेंगे सिंपल सा फंडा है यार तो हम क्या
एक्सेस करेंगे मार्केटिंग इसको कॉपी मार
लिया
देखो देखो भाई देखो क्या मिला मार्केटिंग
कॉपी मारा यहां पे
एंड यहां पे टेस्ला के जगह पे मार्केटिंग
कर देते हैं ए s3 अब देखते हैं इसमें क्या
है अब ये देखिए यह देखिए मार्केटिंग वाले
में यहां पे बहुत सारी बकेट्स मिल रही है
आपको बहुत सारी यह
देखिए यह कुछ वीडियो फाइल्स है कुछ
जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल्स है ये जो की है ना
की ये फाइल्स है की जो है फाइल्स होती है
बकेट के अंदर में में अ आईजी व होम स्टडी
वीडियो सेगमेंट्स ठीक है अ जावा फाइल ठीक
है आईजी व ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है आईजी ये
मनी नीच
अ टेली सेमिनार एमपी3 कुछ करके है यहां पे
मंडे वीडियो कुछ करके आया अब जैसे ये कोई
वीडियो फाइल है मंडे वीडियो ठीक है ना अब
मुझे इसको एक्सेस करना है तो मैं इसको
कॉपी करूंगा इस की की फाइल को और यहां पे
इसके आगे में मैं यहां पे सिंपल ये लगा
दूंगा और एंटर करूंगा टू एक्सेस इट तो ये
एक्सेस होना स्टार्ट हो जाएगा और ये
वीडियो फाइल जो है डाउनलोड होना शुरू हो
चुका है अब मैं इसको अगर ओपन करूं वैसे ही
ओपन नहीं करना चाहिए कोई भी फाइल को
डायरेक्टली आप ओपन मत कीजिएगा यह आपकी
आपसे रिक्वेस्ट है ये सही नहीं है ये आप
देख सकते
हैं सो दिस इज समथिंग कोई वीडियो है मैं
इसको क्लोज कर देता हूं ड्यू टू सो दैट वी
कैन नॉट वी डोंट हिट द कॉपीराइट इश्यूज
एंड यहां पे आपको और भी चीजें हैं यहां पे
सुसन मैसेज एफएल पी लाइक यह किसका है ये
मंडे वीडियो यह है आईजी व्यू होम स्टडी
वीडियो तो यह देख लेते हैं किसका किसका
लीक है ये आईजी व चलिए यहां पर सर्च कर
लेते हैं आईज होम स्टूडियो कुछ है क्या
ये होम स्टडी आईजीवी यह क्या है
[संगीत]
आईजीवी समथिंग आईजीवी आई कुछ होगा कोई
सर्विस होगी चलो ठीक है तो उनका यह लीड है
यहां पर आपको सारी चीज मिल रही है ठीक है
यह समझ में आ रहा है एवरीवन प्लीज इधर
ध्यान दीजिए आप लोग चैट से निकल के इधर
ध्यान दीजिए यह समझ में आ रहा है आपको अब
यहां प बूट कैप टेस्टिमोनियल वीडियो ये
बहुत बड़ी फाइल थी तो हमने एक्सेस कर लिया
इसको सिंपल ये वीडियोस फाइल है बहुत
ज्यादा कुछ इसमें अब नहीं है हम और भी चीज
देखेंगे अब देखते जाइए यहां पे और भी
इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें मिल सकती है बड़ी
फाइल्स 9 एबी की है
ये आपको इसमें ऐसी ऐसी बकेट्स मिल जाएंगी
जो किसी पर्टिकुलर सेगमेंट से बिलोंग करती
है तो आपको बहुत ज्यादा मजा
आएगा एक पर्टिकुलर
सब डोमेन की लिस्ट के लिए भी आप जा सकते
हैं सब डोमेन की लिस्ट निकाल सकते हैं
उसके लिए भी जा सकते हैं 5.4 एब की है ये
1.7gb की हैय प्रोमो प्रोमो करके कुछ है
1.7 जीब की कुछ खास यहां पर तो नहीं है 47
एबी की है नॉट मच 147 ऑब्जेक्ट है लेकिन
इसमें ब्राइट स्पॉट ब्राइट स्पॉट ठीक है
और कोई बड़ी फाइल अगर कुछ मिलती है तो वी
कैन सी
[संगीत]
दैट
नथिंग नथिंग कुछ तो
मिलेगा जीरो बाइट जीरो बाइट जीरो
बाइट सा एमबी 9.2 जीबी य तो हमने देख ही
लिया तो नीचे जाते हैं हम सबसे नीचे चलते
हैं लेट्स गो डाउन यर एंड लेट्स सी 4 एमबी
4 एमबी यहां पर बकेट हंटिंग ब हंटिंग बहुत
कुछ मिल सकता है भाई अभी तो देखते जाओ 18
एबी की ये चीज है 55 ऑब्जेक्ट है इसमें
इंगेज वाले में अब ये क्या है देखने से
पता चलेगा देखना पड़ेगा हमें 484
केबी 22 केबी 400 34 3740 ऑब्जेक्ट है
इसमें ये यूज कर सकते हैं इमेज एनएस क्या
है भाई इतनी ज्यादा क्या है इसके अंदर में
तो लेट्स सी इतने सारे हैं इसके अंदर यार
लेट्स सी कहां गया
हमारा चलो सर्च यहां पर डाल लेते हैं डॉट
ए3
एनड कॉ लेट्स सी क्या है भाई इसके
अंदर ओ
हो यह इमेजेस है इमेजेस है ओके सो व्ट
काइंड ऑफ इमेजेस आर
दज कौन सी इमेज है भाई लेट्स
सी
ये क्या
हुआ ओके अच्छा कोई किसी वेबसाइट की है यह
पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट की है यह ठीक है कोई
बात नहीं लेट ट लेट इट
गो 400 ए इतनी फाइल्स थी या तो मुझे लगा
कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग होगा 460 एबी की नान
ऑब्जेक्ट है यहां पर नीची फाई य नीची फाई
करके कुछ मिला है 18 एबी की है इंगेज
करके यह टूल सही है हा सही है
रिकॉर्ड करके रख दीजिएगा डाटा डाउनलोड कर
लूंगा मैं टेंशन मत लो यहां पे हां एक चीज
और देखना है आपको जैसे यह 4.8 एबी है ना
यहां पे तो इस वाले बकेट के लिए ऑल यूजर
का परमिशन देख लीजिएगा रीड का परमिशन है
फुल कंट्रोल परमिशन अभी तक हमें मिला नहीं
है फुल कंट्रोल मिले तो बहुत मजा आएगा 420
एब 60 ऑब्जेक्ट्स है फ्रंट फ्रंट है
ये फुल कंट्रोल मिले और भी मजा आ जाए
[संगीत]
भाई 82
एमबी 88 केबी 39 एी 15 ऑब्जेक्ट रीड का
परमिशन ओनली ठीक है कोई बात नहीं चलेगा
चलेगा 97 994 एबी य क्या है यह भी इमेज है
क्या पायलट पायलट भाई क्या है हमारे चलिए
पायलट लेट्स गो टू द पायलट
पाइल s3
amazon.com पायलट में इतने ज्यादा है क्या
बताऊं मैं ओ हो यह है क्या
[संगीत]
बट क्लाइंस अकेडमी च जेप फ्रंट क्या हैय
यार लेट्स एक्सेस
इट लेट्स ट्राई
टू एक्सेस
दिस टिंग
टाना
ओके नो सच कीज यहां
पर अवेलेबल नहीं है ठीक है कोई बात नहीं
पॉप अंडर ग्रेजुएशन कुछ ऐसे कुछ है किसी
किसी कॉलेज वगैरह का य लग रहा है यह जहां
तक मुझे लग रहा है सम कॉलेज
राइट योर फोन एफिलिएट न्यूजलेटर कुछ कॉलेज
का य यस राइट तो यह डाटा बहुत स डाटा है
यार इसके अंदर तोल ल लट ऑफ डाटा ओ माय गॉड
चलिए अब यहां पे और डाटा देखते हैं कुछ
बड़ी सी ऐसे रीड राइट के साथ मिल जाती मजा
आ
जाता 2.4 जीब क्या ये फेस्टिवल 2.4 जीब
देखो 2.4 जीब का रीड परमिशन है हमारे पास
नॉट राइट बट यस हां अब एक चीज आप देखते
हैं सील आई का यूज कर लेते हैं इसमें कुछ
मिला क्या भैया इसमें कुछ नहीं मिल रहा
इसको मैं क्लोज कर देता हूं एंड यहां पे
मैं वापस से इसको एग्जीक्यूट कर देता हूं
ताकि मैं यहां पे कुछ और कर पाऊ तो
डन अब मैं क्या करता हूं देखो इस वाले से
निकालते हैं यहां
से यहां से चीजें आ रही है चीजें आ रही है
यहां पे बहुत सारी चीजें आ रही है मैं 1 ओ
हो हो वेब स्टैटिक 13 जीब की फाइल है भाई
13 जीब की वेब स्टैटिक है अब मुझे इसको
लिस्ट करना है मैं इसको कॉपी करूंगा 13
जीब वाली रीड का परमिशन ओनली ठीक है चलेगा
अब मैं यहां पे एडब सी यूज करूंगा एड
s3 एल ए एंड s3 बकेट को हमें लिस्ट करना
है कौन सा बकेट है भैया तो हमने जो अभी
कॉपी किया उसको यहां पे पेस्ट मारने का और
एंटर करने के एंटर करेंगे ये एरर दे देगा
एरर क्यों दे देगा क्योंकि हमने अभी नो
साइन इन वाला नहीं डाला नो साइन
रिक्वेस्ट अब च अब देखते हैं अब देखिए
जैसे ही हमने किया ये पूरी उसकी लिस्ट
यहां पे आ चुकी है इसके अंदर जो जो चीजें
हैं सारी लिस्ट आ चुकी है देखिए ए टू जेड
अभी देखो हॉलीडे बैनर क्रॉस डोमेन
एक्सल ठीक है
सोशल एनल लीगल ठीक है होम पेज ओके सीएमएस
ब्लॉग न्यू फोल्डर इंफो ग्राफिक्स
सीएमएस कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग है क्या कुछ इसके
अंदर
भाई प्री एनल है यहां पर टेस्ट है कुछ खास
तो मुझे नहीं लग रहा इसके
अंदर नो नथिंग
मच
एल एनल में यह प्री एनल आ गया एक और यह
एनल फोल्डर है बस दो ही चीज ठीक एल में
ठीक है तो यह सारी चीज हमारे पास आ चुकी
है अगर इसको हम वैसे एक्सेस करना चाहते
हैं आप वेब प तो आप वेब प भी एक्सेस कर
लीजिए कोई दिक्कत नहीं है यहां
पर क्या है बकेट का नाम क्या है भाई बकेट
का बकेट का नाम था वेब
स्टैटिक वेब स्टैटिक ठीक है तो हमने दे
दिया वेब स्टैटिक ड ए3 एड
एजन एजन एडब्ल्यू एस अभी तो मैं बहुत
खतरनाक चीज बताऊंगा भाई अभी तुम देखते जाओ
अभी रुकते जाओ यह क्या है
भाई
amazon.com वेब क्या हो रहा है यह क्या
दिक्कत
है अभी तो हमने देखा ना अभी तो हमने इसको
यूज
किया
क्या दिक्कत आ रही है वेब स्टिक ए3
डन
कॉ ओके यहां पर हम एक्सेस नहीं कर पा रहे
यह चीज
देख यह चीज आप देख रहे य पर इसको हम इस पर
एक्सेस नहीं कर पा रहे गा am.com प हम
इसको एक्सेस नहीं कर पा रहे
हैं बट वी कैन एक्सेस
ऑन
हियर
ओके डन डन
डन लेट्स एक्सेस अ स्ल
एनल स्ल
एनल नॉप्स वी कैन एक्सेस थ्रू सीआई सीएआई
के थ्रू हम एक्सेस कर पा रहे हैं
दैट्ची फाइल दिख रही है अगर कोई फाइल को
कॉपी वगैरह करना है तो यू कैन डू कॉपी एंड
इतना बग बाउंटीज के लिए काफी होता है बग
बाउंट जब आप कर रहे हैं जब आप एक्सेस कर
पा रहे हैं कोई भी अ रिसोर्स को तो आपको
वहां पे बेसिकली यह दिखाना होता है कि आप
राइट भी कर पा रहे हैं उस रिसोर्स में वो
तब वैलिड मानते हैं ठीक है राइट अगर कर पा
रहे हैं उसको कोई चीज डिलीट कर पा रहे हैं
उस पर्टिकुलर बकेट का उसको वैलिड आपका मिस
कंफिट मानेंगे ठीक है वैलिड उसको मानेंगे
याद रखिएगा राइट का होना चाहिए तो हमारे
पास वो परमिशन अगर हो तो बढ़िया है जैसे
मैं यहां पे नीचे जा रहा हूं यहां पे मुझे
सिर्फ रीड वाले परमिशन अभी मिल रहे हैं
ओनली रीड वाले मिले अभी तक हमें कोई भी
फुल कंट्रोल तो नहीं मिला हमें रीड रीड
रीड एसीपी रीड रीड रीड वी डिंट
गेट टोटल ये देखो 17 जीब की फाइल है भाई
ये स्टैकिंग वन ये तुम देख रहे हो 17b की
यार तुम्हें समझ में आ रहा है 17b क्या
होता है
भाई दिस इ 17b
फाइल अ 28gb की फाइल है ये स्टैटिक सि
वाली तो ये तुम्हें मिल रहा है अब यहां पे
ये रीड रीड का आ रहा है ना परमिशन बाकी जो
परमिशन नहीं आ रहे हैं उसमें आप कुछ नहीं
कर सकते हो रीड वाले परमिशन को एटलीस्ट
देख सकते हो अब मुझे चाहिए सिर्फ रीड वाले
मुझे लाने है तो मेरे पास एक और फंडा है
मैं करूंगा सेम कमांड में ग्रेप लगा दूंगा
एंड ग्रेप लगा के मैं यहां पे रीड डाल
दूंगा अब मुझे जो रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे वो
सिर्फ रीड वाले ही रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे बाकी
रिजल्ट्स नहीं मिलेंगे जो फालतू क रहे थे
ना जिसको हम कुछ नहीं कर पा रहे वो नहीं
मिलेंगे मुझे देखो देखो
अभी इसको तो मैं क्लियर कर देता
हूं अब मुझे इसमें जो रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे
देखो सिर्फ रीड वाले मिल रहे है देख रहे
हो रीड रीड
वाले ये तुमने फिल्टरिंग कर ली थोड़ी सी
ठीक
है इसको तुम राइट फिर राइट वाले भी कर लो
ना राइट वाले भी कर लो राइट वाला जो
ऑब्जेक्शन जो है ना वो वाला लगा दो ग्रैब
कर लो राइट
वाला ठीक है जैसे यहां पे ये किया ना यहां
पे राइट का लगा दो
ना डबल आर आई टी ई राइट इस तरीके से ग्रैब
कर दो अगर राइट का परमिशन कोई होता है तो
अगर तुम्हें देखना है इसका कोड देखना है
कोड बेस वगैरह तो कोड में देख सकते हो
क्या है इनके किस तरीके से चीजें हुई हैं
यहां पे जैसे हमने यहां पे चलो हम कोड को
देख लेते हैं ए3 स्कैनर है ना यह रहा s3
स्कैनर राइट तो यहां
पे अच्छा पहले यह पाइथन की टूल थी यह बाद
में इन्होंने क्या किया था बाद में
इन्होंने इसको चेंज कर दिया गो में गो में
राइट डाउन कर दिया है ना
अ
रन कॉन्फिन के कॉन्फिन फाइल है क्या अच्छा
यह पोस्ट ग की फाइल है
बढ़िया लेट्स चेक लेट्स चेक लेट्स चक लेटस
चक
लेटक रिलीज वामल यहां पर एक बार देख लेते
हैं आ रही है क्या हमारे पास कुछ राइट का
कुछ हमने राइट दिया देखो राइट के बाद कोई
रिजल्ट नहीं आ अभी तक क्योंकि राइट वाली
परमिशन कोई बकेट मिली नहीं इनको वी डिन
गेट एनी राइट परमिशन ठीक है कोई भी अभी
राइट वाली परमिशन हमें नहीं मिली अभी
देखते जाओ भाई थोड़ा इंतजार करो अभी टूल्स
पे है इसके बाद तो हम बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग
चीज देखने वाले हैं बहुत खतरनाक चीज आने
वाली है
अभी ठीक है यह चीज मिल गई
अब
हां जी यहां पर कोई भी राइट वाली नहीं
मिली हमें कोई भी हमें राइट वाली अभी तक
नहीं मिली है लेट्स अगर आपको मिल जाती है
यू कैन गेट द राइट वाली परमिशन वाली एंड
आपको बहुत सारी चीजें इंटरेस्टिंग स्टेप्स
जो है वो मिल जाएंगी ठीक है चलिए ये तो
आपको समझ में आ गया अब मुझे ये बता दीजिए
ये टूल्स का सबका क्लियर है दोनों टूल्स
का क्लियर हो गया आप लोगों का लेट मी नो
प्लीज एवरीवन दोनों टूल्स का आप लोगों को
क्लियर हो चुका है s3 बकेट मिस कन्फर्ट को
फाइंड करने में ये टूल्स का रोल लेज s3
एंड s3 स्कैनर इसके अलावा देयर आर मल्टीपल
टूल्स दैट यू कैन यूज आल्सो बहुत सारे
टूल्स हैं जिसको आप यूज कर सकते
हैं
ऑसम
s3 s3 बकेट ऐसे करके टूल्स आपको मैं दिखा
देता हूं यह वाली यह वाली रिपोजिटरी है
यहां पे s3 बकेट के न्यूमरेशन से रिलेटेड
बहुत सारी टूल्स है यह सारी टूल्स हैं इन
सबको आप यूज कर सकते हैं ग्रे हैट वरफेन
स्लर्प एड बकेट डंप s3 स्कैनर ये सारी
चीजें ए3 एनएम ये इंस्पेक्टर सब ये यूज कर
सकते हैं इसके लिए स्पेसिफिकली ठीक है तो
ये तो आपको अब समझ में आ गया होगा बहुत
सिंपल सा फंडा है बहुत सिंपल सा चीज है अब
मैं आपको यहां पे एक और इंटरेस्टिंग चीज
बताता हूं तरीका बताता हूं जिससे
कि जिससे कि आप क्या करेंगे आपको पता
चलेगा कि बकेट्स लीक्ड बकेट्स मिलने के
आपके चांसेस जो है वो बढ़ जाएंगे दूसरा जो
मेथड है वो मेथड है आपका एक डोमेन एक
वेबसाइट का यूज करना जो कि मे लिस्ट में
सबसे प्रायोरिटी प थी एंड बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग आपको लगने वाला है बहुत
ज्यादा ठीक है लेट आओगे तो थोड़ा-थोड़ा ही
समझ में आएगा लेट लेट आए हो तुम बाकी
लोगों जो टाइम पे वो समझ में आ जाएंगे
उनको ठीक है लेट मत आया करो यार इतना मैं
बोलता हूं लेट मत लेट मत हो लेट मत हो चलो
अब मैं एक और इंटरेस्टिंग एक वेबसाइट की
मैं बता रहा हूं जिसका नाम है ग्रे हैट वर
फेयर यह बहुत बहुत पॉपुलर वेबसाइट है
जिसमें आपको पब्लिक
एक्सेसिबल एडब्ल्यू एस बकेट्स मिलते हैं
बहुत पॉपुलर वेबसाइट हर एक हंटर हर एक बग
बाउंट रिसर्चर इसका यूज करता है अब इसमें
एक चीज मैं आपको बता बताता हूं वह आप
समझिए पहले यह वेबसाइट बिल्कुल स्पून
फीडिंग वाला काम करता है एक तरह से लेकिन
आपके पास सर्च स्किल्स होने चाहिए सर्च
स्किल्स कैसे क्या सर्च स्किल्स मैं आपको
दिखाता हूं
देखिए रेक्स डॉक्स यहां आ रहे है यह डॉक्स
है रेक्स डॉक्स इसम हम आएंगे और इसको हम
थोड़ा समझेंगे कैसे इस यूज करना है अब आप
आएंगे जब इस पे गहे wf2 पे bucket.com पे
तो बाकी सारी चीजें आप भूल जाइए और यह एक
वन ऑल इन वन सॉल्यूशन है आपके s3 हंटिंग
के ऊपर क्यों क्योंकि यहां पे टोटल
2.7 बिलियंस ऑफ फाइल्स आपके पड़े हैं
एडब्ल्यू के इतने चीजें जो है ना आप
ऑलरेडी ये ऐड करते रहते हैं रेगुलर बेसिस
पे ये स्कैन करते हैं लास्ट अपडेट इनका 19
जनवरी 2024 का था 19 जनवरी 2024 का अभी
कुछ दिन पहले की और इसमें आप पर्टिकुलर
खोद सकते हैं
लीगड्डा
देंगे रिजल्ट आपको अच्छा नहीं मिलेगा आप
इफेक्टिव कीवर्ड डालेंगे तो आपको उतना ही
अच्छा रिजल्ट मिलेगा क्योंकि आपकी तरह
बहुत सारे हैकर्स इसको सर्च कर रहे हैं
सबसे बड़ी बात यह फ्री में लिमिटेड रखता
है रिजल्ट्स को याद रखिए खगा फ्री में कुछ
चीजें आप यूज नहीं कर सकते जैसे रेक्स
वाली इसको आप यूज नहीं कर सकते फुल पाथ
वाली यूज नहीं कर सकते एडिशनल फिल्टर्स
नहीं लगा सकते सिंपल सर्च कर सकते हैं बट
इसके पेड वाले में आप सब कुछ कर सकते हैं
इसके लिए सिंपल आप प्राइसिंग देख सकते हैं
मैं आपको दिखा ही देता हूं लेट्स सी इसको
मैं क्लोज कर देता हूं लेट्स क्लोज
इट इनको मैं क्लोज कर देता हूं फिलहाल के
लिए इनकी जरूरत तो नहीं है गिट बरे कौन से
भी आप एडब्ल्यू एस के बकेट्स फाइंड कर
सकते हैं या रखिएगा एडब सीक्रेट ड सीक्रेट
एक्सेस और आईडी यूजर
आईडी फ्री वाले में यहां पे अगर आप
रजिस्टर्ड यूजर है आपको रजिस्टर्ड होना
पड़ेगा यहां पे रजिस्टर्ड नहीं है तो
रजिस्टर्ड हो जाइएगा ज्यादा बढ़िया है तो
मैं यहां पे लॉग इन कर लेता हूं एक बार तो
मैं यहां
पे लॉग इन कर लेता हूं आई डोंट नो मुझे
कि मुझे याद नहीं है कि ये सेम पासवर्ड है
कि नहीं इसका बट स्टिल आई एम
लॉगइन हो गया अरे यार मेरे को याद नहीं
रहता बट फिर भी लॉगइन हो जाता
है ठीक है अब यहां पे फ्री वाले में अगर
आप रजिस्टर्ड यूजर है फ्री में ही विजिटर
है तब तो बहुत कम है रजिस्टर्ड है तो आपको
फाइल सर्च लिमिट इतनी मिलेगी सर्च
रिजल्ट्स लिस्टिंग इतनी मिलेगी दोनों के
डिफरेंस रजिस्टर में देख लीजिए ना आप
रजिस्टर ही होंगे ना 2000 बकेट फाइल
लिस्टिंग 2000 2000 ऐसे करके अगर आप इसके
प्रीमियम यूजर है जिसके लिए आपको 25 यूरो
पर मंथ देना पड़ेगा यानी ये वर्थ है अगर
आप स्पेसिफिकली बकेट हंटिंग में है ना तो
आपको बाउंट लग जाएगी और आपकी य 25 यूरो
निकल जाएंगे इतना मुझे पता है क्योंकि ये
p1 प2 कैटेगरी में आ जाएगा डायरेक्टली अगर
आपका वैसे कोई कोई बकेट आप लिस्ट एक्सेस
कर पाते हैं उसको री उसको राइट कर पाते
हैं उसको डिलीट कर पाते हैं कंटेंट को
राइट कर पाते हैं अपलोड कर पाते हैं अपना
पीओ तो यू कैन
इजली सरपास दिस प्राइसिंग तो ये 25 यूरो
है तो यूरो टू आईआर अगर हम देखें तो यहां
पर 25 अगर डालते हैं तो अप्रॉक्स
2255 एक महीने के कॉस्टली है आई नो बट
स्टिल अगर आप बहुत ज्यादा फ्रीक्वेंसी में
बहुत ज्यादा चीजें कर चुके हैं एक लेवल पे
आ चुके हैं तो यू कैन गो फॉर इट अदर वाइज
आप फ्री वाला प्लान ी इसको फ्री वाला
प्लान ही यूज कीजिए यू डोंट नीड अ पेड
प्लान ठीक है
चलिए अब यहां पे मैं आ जाता हूं एंड यहां
पे मैं क्या करता हूं मैं यहां पे कुछ भी
सर्च करूंगा सर्च करने का तरीका देखिए
कैसे बता रखा है स्टॉप वट्स कैसे लगाने है
जैसे मान लो आप सीक्रेट सर्च कर रहे हैं
तो सारे फाइल्स रिटर्न करेगा जिसमें
सीक्रेट होगा फाइल नेम में और अगर सीक्रेट
माइनस एचटीएमएल कर देंगे तो सारे फाइल्स
रिटर्न करेगा जिसमें सीक्रेट हो लेकिन
एचटीएमएल ना हो फाइल नेम में इस तरीके से
तो अब आपकी जिम्मेदारी है आप फटाफट दिमाग
में खुरा पाती दिमाग लगाइए अपने चंचल
दिमाग को चलाइए और मुझे कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग
कीवर्ड्स बताइए जो हम सर्च करें तो वो
फाइल नेम में आए और वो फाइल्स हमें यहां
लिस्ट में रिजल्ट्स में मिले सोचो वो फाइल
नेम में आएगी याद रखिएगा ये जो आप कीवर्ड
बताएंगे वो फाइल के नाम में आएगा और वो
फाइल्स लिस्ट होके यहां पे आएंगी समझ में
आ रहा है तो कुछ ऐसे इंटरेस्टिंग कीवर्ड्स
बताइए ताकि आपको कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग फाइल्स
मिले इस पर्टिकुलर ग्रे हैट वरफेन पे
देखते हैं आपका रिजेक्स सर्च कितना
इंटरेस्टिंग है किस तरीके से आप डाल सकते
हैं कीवर्ड्स को ये मुझे देखना आप लोगों
से जो भी है वो बताइए मुझे ये तो ईमेल
पासवर्ड बहुत ही कॉमन सा कीवर्ड हो गया
याद रखिएगा बहुत कॉमन कीवर्ड हो गया कुछ
दिमाग
लगाइए जस्ट ऐड योर माइंड और यहां पे
एक्सटेंशन देना होता है कौन सा एक्सटेंशन
आप यूज करना चाहते हैं फ्री यूजर जो है वो
पांच एक्सटेंशन मैक्सिमम यूज कर सकते हैं
तो पीएचपी वाली जो चीज है इसको हम हटा
देते हैं नहीं चाहिए मुझे एक्सेल एस ठीक
है एक्सेल फाइल है कुछ डिटेल्स निकल सकती
है डॉक फाइल अभी नहीं चाहिए पीडीएफ ठीक है
टी एक्सटी लगा देता हूं मैं टी एक्सटी
इंटरेस्टिंग हो सकता है एटीएमएल सकता हूं
मैं एंड एक मैं लगा देता
हूं बैकअप लगा दूं क्या या बैक बीए
बैक कई बार कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग चीज निकल के आ
जाती है चलिए देखते
हैं यूजर
डीबी क्रेडिट कार्ड यह तो बेकार कीवर्ड
है अक्षय आर ने बोला यूजर
डीबी चलिए तो यूजर डीबी कर लेते एक बार
यूजर डीबी थोड़ा इंटरेस्टिंग लग रहा है
मैंने यूजर डीबी कर लिया यहां पर ठीक है
सिंपल यूजर डीपी
किया
एंड ठीक है एंड यहां पर जैसे यूजर डीबी
सर्च किया मैं यूजर डीबी मैंने लिखा एंड
यहां पे सर्च प क्लिक करूंगा एक बार सर्च
करो पहले देखते हैं पहले क्या रिजल्ट आता
है जैसे ही मैंने रिजल्ट यहां पे सर्च
किया यहां पे आपको यहां प रिजल्ट्स दिखने
शुरू हो गए यहां पे देखिए प्रीमियम यूजर्स
यूजिंग दिस क्वेरी सी सेवन मोर रिजल्ट्स
मतलब प्रीमियम को सात और रिजल्ट्स मिलते
हैं कोई बात नहीं अब यहां पे आपको लिस्ट
मिल गई है एचटीएमएल फाइल ये यूजर डीब की
यहां पे यह देखो कुछ है यहां पे इसको ओपन
करना है क्लिक कीजिए यहां पे यह ओपन होके
आ जाएगा यहां पे बेसिकली यहां पे डाउनलोड
हो गई एटीएल फाइल यहां पे क्लिक किया और
यहां पे यूजर डीवी का एक फाइल है यहां पे
ये क्लिक होके यहां पे आ गया अब इसके अंदर
आप मल्टीपल चीजें और फाइंड कर सकते हैं
लाइक कोई और क्रेडेंशियल है पासवर्ड है
यूजर नेम अ यूजर नेम कुछ है यहां पे यूजर
नेम है यहां पे ओके लेट्स गिव अ
पासवर्ड पासवर्ड ऐसा कुछ अ फिलहाल कुछ भी
नहीं है कुछ लिंक्स वगैरह भी आप यूज कर
सकते हैं ठीक है मान लो ये हो गया अब इस
तरीके से और भी फाइल्स यहां पे आपको मिल
रही है यहां पे
मान लो बहुत सारे एटीएमएल रिजल्ट आए तो हम
एचटीएमएल को हटाते हैं बाकी रिजल्ट्स के
लिए तो हम यहां पर पीएचपी कर देते हैं एंड
अब हम सर्च करते
हैं
चलिए हमें कुछ रिजल्ट्स नहीं मिला है
क्योंकि हमें और कोई चीज एजिस्ट नहीं करती
है ठीक है बढ़िया अब मुझे क्या चाहिए मैं
कुछ और यूज करता हूं सीक्रेट एडमिन चलिए
सीक्रेट एडमिन ये यूआरएल के लिए मैंने
बोला था आप लोग कुछ शायद कुछ और समझ रहे
हैं इसलिए यहां पर कोई फाइल नहीं आएगी
यहां पर कुछ भी नहीं रिजल्ट
[संगीत]
आएगा
कॉन्फिन फिग लगा लेता हूं कॉन्फिन लेते
हैं एंड लेट्स सी वी गट अ लॉट ऑफ रिजल्ट्स
बहुत सारे रिजल्ट्स मिले हमें एंड यहां पे
आप देख रहे होंगे ये काफी सारे रिजल्ट्स
हम यहां प मिल चुके हैं अ लॉट लॉट ऑफ
रिजल्ट्स यहां प आप देख सकते हैं
डब्ल्यूपी
कॉन्फिन साइट की है यह यह फाइल डब्ल्यूपी
कॉन्ग डॉट पीएचपी फाइल है ये तो ओबवियसली
वी गेट द पीएचपी फाइल हियर बाकी कॉन्ग डटी
एक्सटी यहां पर मिल रही है यहां
पे नीचे आ जाइए यहां पे बहुत सारी चीजें
जनरेटर
कफ यहां पर जनरेटर जनरेटर काफी सारे मिल
रहे हैं तो मैं जनरेटर को माइनस कर देता
हूं माइनस जनरेटर एंटर करता हूं मैं
अब अब देखते हैं रिजल्ट्स बहुत सारे य हो
चुके हैं फिल्टर हो चुके थोड़े से तो यहां
पर आप देख सकते हैं डप कड पीएपी फाइल मिल
रही है यहां पे ये फाइ मिल र है आपको
थोड़ा सा दिमाग लगाना पड़ेगा यहां पे ये
पीडीएफ पीडीएफ मिल रही है यहां पे अब मैं
क्या करता हूं यहां पे सिर्फ टेक्स्ट फाइल
को कॉपी करता हूं मैं पीडीएफ को भी हटा
देता हूं यहां पे पीएचपी भी हटा देता हूं
मैं बैकअप टेक्स्ट एक्सलस एंड यहां पे मैं
कर देता
[संगीत]
हूं बैकअप तो कर लिया
हमने
लॉग लॉग वाला भी कर देता हूं अब मैं सर्च
करता हूं लेट्स सी इफ यू आर गेटिंग सम
रिजल्ट्स कुछ फिल्टर आउट हो जाएंगे यहां
पे अब देखिए यहां प साइट
कॉन्फिडेंस फाइल ओपन हो रही है यहां पे ये
कुछ एक टीएस फाइल ग्रुप कॉन्फिन की एक्सटी
फाइल ओपन हुई है यहां पे कुछ कॉन्फिन की
डिटेल्स है यहां पे देन अगेन वी कैन फाइंड
कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग देखते हैं कुछ अगर कुछ
ऐसे मिल जाए प्लग इन
बैकअप बैक डब्ल्यूपी अप ग्रुप कॉन्फिन पर
कुछ एक फाइल है कॉन्फिन की एन वी कैन गो
डाउन यह देखिए कॉग जए
डॉट बैक फाइल है यह तो ओबवियसली डॉट बैक
फाइल है आपकी
य यू कैन सिंपली रिनेम इट अब इसको रिनेम
कर दीजिए डॉट बैक को हटा
दीजिए डॉट जीएस फाइल है य अब एक तोड जस
फाइल को आप ओपन विथ नोटपैड कर दीजिए या
एडिट विथ नोटपैड कर दीजिए इसको ओपन कर
लीजिए एंड इट विल ओपन इट तो यहां पर आपको
जो है इसके डिटेल जो है इसके अंदर जो भी
चीज है आपको यहां पर मिल जाती है कोई भी
फाइल को ओपन कर सकते इस तरीके से आप यहां
पे ये एक्सलस
है चलिए एक्सेल फाइल है देखते हैं क्या है
इसके अंदर एसीसी एनपी कुछ करके ये एक्सेल
फाइल है वी गॉट सम एक्सेस फाइल एंड यहां
पे क्या मिला ये यह
देखिए कंपनी नेम है यहां पे बूथ नंबर
है एंड व्हाट इज दिस नेचुरल प्रोडक्ट है
ट्रू है एंड यहां पे इसकी कॉन्फिन मिली है
नेचुरल प्रोडक्ट तो ये कुछ कंपनी नेम है
चार्ल्स चॉकलेट्स अ हम फी अ कुछ है लव
बीट्स है यहां पे यह बाहर की कोई फॉरेन
कंपनी है अ एंड इनके कुछ बूथ नंबर है एंड
ये इनका कैटेगरी दिया हुआ है नेचुरल
प्रोडक्ट्स का यूज़ करते हैं कि नहीं करते
हैं ट्रू फॉल्स ये सब कुछ दिया हुआ है
इसमें ये सारी चीजें ये ट्रू वाले हैं
सारे तो ये आपको एक लिस्ट ली कंपनी की मिल
गई यहां पे अ कुछ इस तरीके से ये भी है
यहां पे a.c.
txt.gz
यर का है ये ओबवियसली य ग क्लाउड का है ये
एड एड्स के है ठीक है तो इस तरीके से आप
सर्च कर सकते जैसे हम थड नंबर पर चलते हैं
यहां
पर
प्रोडक्शन ओके इसको देखते क्या रिसिप्ट
टाइप का कुछ है क्या है यह अलाउ डाउनलोड
लेट्स डाउनलोड इट एंड लेट्स ओपन इट मिनिमम
मॉड्यूल पैरामीटर व्ट इ दिस ट टस टस टपल
क्लास नेम स्पियरमन यहां
पे कुछ फाइल है ये कन्फ फाइल ये फिर यहां
पर और भी कन्फी फाइल है इस तरीके से मतलब
देर आर लॉट ऑफ थिंग्स अब मुझे यहां पर
क्या करना है मैं यहां पर क्या करूंगा अब
एक काम करता हूं लेट्स लेट्स डू वन थिंग
अब मैं यहां पे कुछ और सर्च करता हूं जैसे
कि लेट्स सर्च फॉर
यूजर यूजर ऐसे सर्च करके ब फिल्टर आउट कर
लेते हैं नथिंग व गट वी गट
नंग व्ट अबाउट
पासवर्ड लेट लेटस साइन इन
लेटस साइन इन नथिंग चलो एक बार ने सर्च
करते हैं
[संगीत]
पेमेंट मास्टर कार्ड एंड यह एड्रेस है एंड
यह डेट है 2021 का तो यली ये चेंज हो गया
होगा पासवर्ड बट स्टिल कुछ रिजल्ट्स आपको
मिल गए यहां पे एंड यह क्या है कूपंस
एक्सलस यह कूपंस क्या
है डिड नॉट पोटेंशियल सिक्योरिटी रिस्क यह
डाउनलोड यह एक्सेसिबल है कि नहीं
यार लेट्स फाइंड आउट इ इफ इट इज
एक्सेसिबल
सो एक बार देख लेते एक्सेसिबल है भी या
नहीं है
कुछ नो सर्टिफिकेट सब्जेक्ट यू नो चेक
सर्टिफिकेट तो नो चेक सर्टिफिकेट यूज कर
लेते हैं हाइ फन हाइन
नो
चेक सर्टिफिकेट देन देखते हैं मिलता कि
नहीं
हमें ओके मिल चुका है क्या
क्या बात
है ओके सो वी गट इट यर एंड हेयर द कपन n
एक्सल बट यह वही है ना फाइल बहुत पुरानी
होगी मेरे ख्याल से जहा तक मुझे लग रहा
है य तक आई कैन सी यर कहां गई यह फाइल
कूपन डायरेक्टली यहां पर आ गई होगी ना
कूपन वाली में वेर इट रट र इट र इट इ अरे
भैया कहां गयो
हो
रूट के
अंदर कूपंस कूपन यह वाली कूपन फाइल आ गई
यहां
पर ओपन कर लेते हैं यहां पे एंड ओपन करते
हैं यहां पर एंड हेयर
आर यह कूपन आईडी यहां पे कुछ कूपन कूपन
मिले यहां पर कुछ कूपन है यहां पर एंड
टाइटल साइट आईडी यहां प है
[संगीत]
तो और कुछ मिला क्या यहां प और कुछ भी
नहीं है एंड लेट्स फाइंड आउट समथिंग मैं
एक काम करता
हूं आधार ए डबल ए ऐसे सर्च करते डबल ए डी
एच ए आर आधार सर्च करते हैं आधार हां ठीक
है आधार सर्च करते हैं एंड आधार में तो
पीडीएफ जरूरी है पीडीएफ डाल देते
हैं लॉग की जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी बैकअप फाइल
की जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी पीडीएफ टी एक्सटी
एक्सल एस डीओ सी एक्स कर सकते हैं डीओ सी
एक्स कर सकते
हैं एंड क्या कर सकते हैं पीडीएफ तो हमें
मिल जाएगी टेक्स्ट फाइल तो मिल रही है आई
एमजी डाल देते इमेज एंड अब सर्च करते
हैं लेट्स
सी यह देखो यह हमें रिजल्ट्स मिल रहे हैं
एंड जहां तक मुझे लग रहा है वही कुछ है
क्या एक बार ओपन करते इसको क्या है
ये कुछ ओके ये कुछ और है यह देखते हैं व्ट
दिस दिस इज
नोटिस यहां पर एक एक्सलस फाइल है आधार कुछ
करके है लेट्स ओपन
इट यह कोई लिस्ट है लिस्ट ऑफ पेंशनर्स
आधार नंबर इ नॉट वैलिड नेवर यूज दिस
डिटेल्स फॉर एनी मलिस वर्क गाइस लवेज यूज
लीगली अच्छा यह आधार डिटेल्स है मुझे लग
रहा है यह सारे आधार डिटेल्स लोगों के यू
कैन सी
यर दज आर सम आधार डिटेल्स
हियर ठीक है वी आर नॉट गोइंग थ्रू इट वी
आर नॉट यूजिंग एनीथिंग लाइक सच इन आवर
वीडियो यह बस आपको डेमन श्रेट करने के लिए
ओएस इ डिस
कनेक्टेड इट्स गेटिंग
कनेक्टिंग ओके डन तो यहां पे बहुत सारी
चीजें यहां पे मिल रही है यहां पे आधार
फ्रंट
आधार बहुत सारे आधार कार्ड य मिल रहे हैं
यार आधार से देखो कितनी सारी लीकेज होती
है आधार से देखो आधार कितने सारे चंडीगढ़
का अपलोड है यह चंडीगढ़ अपलोड है चंडीगढ़
के आधार डटा है यह सारे लाइव बैकअप में
यहां पर कुछ है हाउसिंग फाइनेंस का कुछ है
यहां पर लेट्स
सी ओके आधार हाउसिंग फाइनेंस का यहां पर
हमारा क्या है यह आधार हाउसिंग फाइनेंस का
डिटेल है यहां
पर इ लाख 80
लाख ओ माय गॉड 80 लाख का इनका इनकम है
एक्सपेंसेस 64 लाख है प्रॉफिट आफ्टर टैक्स
जो
है लेट्स
सी प्रॉफिट फॉर द टाइम पीरियड
99000 कुछ ऐसे मतलब यह डिटेल्स इनके कुछ
ठीक है कोई बात नहीं लेट्स
गो
या नहीं नहीं उसके उससे कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है हमने बस वो शो किया है कि दिस आर दिस
थिंग्स आर विजिबल बाकी हम कुछ यूज नहीं कर
रहे हैं यह भी कुछ आधार कार्ड का य
डिटेल्स वगर यह सारे आधार कार्ड है यहां
पर आते हैं नीचे एंड लेट्स सी व्ट इज दिस
दिस आल्सो रिलेटेड टू
आधार
एवरीथिंग इ रिलेटेड टू
आधार सो चलिए यह तो आधार हो गया अब हम कुछ
और डिटेल्स भी य पर सर्च कर लेते हैं जैसे
मैं यूआरएल में जैसे फाइल ने में मुझे
चाहिए जैसे अभी रिजल्ट आ र ना फाइल ने में
आपको ये रिजल्ट आ रहे आपको आधार ऐसे कुछ
लिखा हुआ रहा है अब लेटस सपोज मुझे
चाहिए हा मुझे क्या चाहिए मैं आधार के
अलावा क्या कर सकता हूं
पासवर्ड यूजर नेम ऐसा कुछ सर्च करता हूं
तो ये क्या
है सम एटीएल फाइल इज
देयर जनरल वेलकम यूजरनेम पासवर्ड वेलकम ड
पीडीएफ व्हाट इज दिस लेट्स ओपन
इट वेलकम पीडीएफ ठीक है है क्या
ये
ओके सम काइंड ऑफ
पेज लेट्स
गो टू द सर्च फील्ड एंड यहां पर सर्च करते
हैं एडमिन एंड यहां पर सर्च करते हैं पास
एडमिन पास लेट्स सी हाउ रिजल्ट्स वी आर
गेटिंग गॉट हियर ये रहा ये कुछ मिला है
मुझे टेक्स्ट फाइल है ये पास यूजर एडमिन
एडमिन v8 कुछ ऐसे ही है सिंपल सा चीज चीज
है एडमिन एफआर पास डेव कुछ पीडीएफ है यहां
पे
अ दिस इज सम पीडीएफ काइंड ऑफ थिंग्स ओके
कोई बात नहीं कोई टेंशन नहीं है चलो मतलब
इस तरीके से आप चीजें सर्च कर सकते हैं अब
देखिए इसमें सर्चिंग का तरीका मैं आपको
बताता हूं कैसे है रेगुलर एक्सप्रेशन सर्च
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन में आप आएंगे इसी के ग्रे
हैट वॉर फेयर के तो यहां पे आप आएंगे तो
देखिए यहां पे क्या किस तरीके से है हाउ
वी इंडेक्स दिस इज अ स्ट्रिप ऑफ ऑल स्मॉल
स्पेशल कैरेक्टर्स यहां पे जैसे स्टूडेंट
रिज्यूम स्ल रिज्यूम बैकअप डॉक इस तरीके
से अगर आप सर्च करते हैं तो यह क्या बिकम
क्या हो जाता है स्टूडेंट एक अलग हो जाता
है रिज्यूम रिज्यूम अलग हो जाता है इस
तरीके से ये अलग-अलग चीज हो जा सकती है
दैट मींस इफ यू सर्च फॉर द बैकअप ये ये
स्टूडेंट यू विल गेट दिस इन द रिजल्ट ठीक
है बट इफ यू ओनली सर्च बैक अप ये यू विल
नॉट फाइंड दिस एंट्री समझ में आ रहा है
देयर इज नो पार्शियल मैच ऑन द कीवर्ड्स
आल्सो इफ सम रीजन यू नीड टू इंक्लूड
स्पेशल कैरेक्टर ऑन द फाइल दिस विल नॉट
वर्क पार्शियल रिजल्ट्स में इसका कुछ ऐसा
हिसाब किताब नहीं है अब जैसे यह बैकअप है
यह वाली बैकअप ये इस तरीके से अगर आप सर्च
करते हैं बैकअप तो यह क्या करेगा सारी
चीजें जो बैकअप कंटेन करता हो जैसे कि यह
सर्च किया एंड हमने क्या
किया यहां से
अ
बैकअप यह सर्च कर लिया अब जो भी बैकअप
वाली चीजें हैं सब मिलेंगी यहां पे ये
देखिए बैकअप वाली पहली बात तो पीडीएफ हटा
देते हैं पीडीएफ की कोई रिक्वायरमेंट अभी
फिलहाल नहीं है हमारे पास तो इसको हटा
देते हैं और यहां पे कर देते हैं बी ए के
भी एक बैक लगा देते हैं इमेज की
रिक्वायरमेंट यहां पे नहीं है इसको भी हटा
देते हैं ठीक है यहां पे हमारी पीएचपी की
रिक्वायरमेंट हो सकती है पीएचपी हम लगा
देते हैं टी एकटी लगा देते हैं बस दैट्ची
कर लेते हैं अब हम जो यहां पे सर्च करके
रिजल्ट्स जो मुझे मिलेगा अब देखिए यहां पे
ये देख रहे हैं बैक अप बैकअप जितने भी बैक
ये देखिए बैक अ डॉट बैक फाइल एक मिली हमें
यहां पे 14gb की ये देख रहे हो तुम ये
देखो बैकअप फाइल कितनी जीबी है ओ भाई ये
बैकअप फाइल है एन ओ आर आर आई क्य ऑपरेशनल
बैकअप 14 जीब की फाइल है ये कुछ तो मिली
है भाई कुछ तो है भैया ये 14 जीब की फाइल
है तुम्हें समझ में आ रहा है ये ओ माय गॉड
टीपीसीसी बैकअप टीपीसीसी क्या है भाई ये
टीपीसीसी देखते हैं टीपीसीसी क्या है ओ हो
हो तेलंगाना प्रदेश कांग्रेस कमेटी का कुछ
बैकअप है क्या
यार कितने जीबी का 7 जीब का है इसको पहले
डाउनलोड करें क्या एंड व्हाट इज
दिस यह कोई एन आर आर आई क्यू एन ओ आर आर
आई क्यू यह कोई उसमें तो नहीं फस जाएंगे
ना हम यार यह कोई सीआरएम
है सीआरएम सर्विस देती है इनका कोई बैकअप
है यह 14 जीबी का ओ हो हो कुछ ज्यादा ही
बड़ा ये सो लेट्स कैंसिल इट ये तेलंगाना
वाला कुछ ये ये मुझे थोड़ा इंटरेस्टिंग लग
रहा है सो लेट्स डाउनलोड दिस 7gb की फाइल
है बट इट विल टेक सम टाइम टू डाउनलोड 7gb
फाइल इट विल टेक सम टाइम
राइट इसको हम वैसे डाउनलोड कर सकते हैं
क्या वीपीएस से अपने कर सकते हैं साजी बी
बट स्टोरेज की वो डिलीट करना पड़ेगा हमें
है
ना सा जीबी की फाइल है वी नीड टू डिलीट इट
एक काम करते हैं कॉपी लिंक एड्रेस डाउनलोड
लिंक ए लेट्स ट्राई टू गेट इट फ्रॉम आवर
ओन वीपीएस अरे भैया हो गया यार कितना
डिस्कनेक्ट हो गया यार डिस्कनेक्ट हो होगे
तुम परेशान हो मैं कनेक्ट कर करके परेशान
हूं चलिए
कांग्रेस सो लेट्स गेट इट लेट्स गेट इट
लेट्स गेट इट 7 जीब की फाइल है है सो
लेट्स सी हाउ मेनी कितना टाइम लगता है
देखते हैं 7 एमबी 8 एबी 10 एमबी 14 एमबी
20 एमबी 25 एमबी ओ हो हो
हो इतनी बड़ी है यार 8 एमबी पर सेकंड का
भी स्पीड आ रहा है स्पीड काफी स्लो आ रहा
है वैसे तो बट स्टिल अभी थोड़ी फास्ट हो
जाएगी बट स्टिल सर्वर पर डिपेंड भी करता
है लाइक कहां से डाउनलोड हो रही है उनकी
क्या स्पीड है तो थोड़ा सा टाइम यहां पे
लग जाएगा अभी 7 8 एबी में तो इसको रहने
देते
हैं हां स्पीड काफी फास्ट है ये मतलब
हमारे पास स्पीड काफी है अभी देखो स्पीड
क्या है मैं दिखाऊं तुम्हें स्पीड
टेस्ट स्पीड टेस्ट कर लेते
हैं ये
देखिए ये देखो क्या है डाउनलोड स्पीड
1716 एबी पर सेकंड 1.7gb पर सेकंड के
आसपास की है ये
ट यह सोर्स से सोर्स पर भी डिपेंड करता है
ट्स वाई तो यहां पर स्पीड थोड़ी सी आपकी
कम आ रही है बट कोई बात नहीं यह बैक फाइल
यहां पर डाउनलोड हो रही थी तो मैं इसको
रिमूव कर देता हूं आर एम टीपीसीसी इसको
बैक को रिमूव कर देते हैं राइट कोई मतलब
नहीं है छोड़ो
ह यहां से डाउनलोड जो हो रहा है इसको होने
देते हैं मैं इसको बाद में देखूंगा लेट इट
कंप्लीट ठीक है तो यह फाइल आ रही है
कुछ प्रोडक्शन वेरीफाई यहां से कुछ नहीं
मिला यहां पर कुछ बहुत सारी चीज मिल सकती
है या तुम अभी अंदाजा नहीं लगा सकते व चीज
मिल सकती है यहां प बक चलिए टीटी फाइल है
क्या
हैय सेकंड पेज पर चलते
हैं मॉड्यूल डॉट बैक फाइल्स आर्काइव
आर्काइव प्रोडक्शन कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें
मिले तो निकाल सकते हो बस इतना चीज इतना
मुझे पता है देखते रना है अप ड्राफ्ट का
बैकअप है यहां पर कुछ ठीक है कोई छोटी
मोटी अच्छी फाइल मिल जाती तो अपन देख भी
लेते बट ठीक है कोई बात
[संगीत]
नहीं नथिंग
मच नहीं होगी भाई नहीं होगी टेंशन नहीं
लेने का वीर जस्ट डूइंग एवरीथिंग फॉर
एजुकेशनल
परपस
एक्सलस है यहां पर आईटी आरओ एक्सलस है
लेट्स ओपन रेसिडेंट एक्सलस कौन सी फाइल है
भाई क्या है यह कहीं और की है य इंडिया की
तो नहीं है बहुत छोटा सा है य ठीक है कई
बार आपको हनी पॉट्स भी मिल सकते हैं ध्यान
रखिएगा थोड़ा सा यह बिलिंग बैकअप है यहां
पर यह है एक स्मार्ट लेवल्स का बैकअप है
2.94 जीब का एई स्मार्ट लेवल्स बैकअप
तो दिस इज समथिंग चलिए टीसीसी बैकअप तो
मैं डाउनलोड इसमें लगा के रखूंगा इसको मैं
डाउनलोड अभी होने दूंगा बाकी अपना यह डाउ
ये चीजें अपना देखते रहिएगा आप लोग यहां
पे कुछ बैकअप डटी फाइल है यहां पे एंड दिस
इज वन
द फ्लैट इकाउंट ठीक है तो मतलब यू कैन गेट
अ लॉट ऑफ जूसी इंफॉर्मेशन फ्रॉम दिस एड ए3
बकेट हंटिंग आपको बहुत स चीज मिल सकती है
ये तो आपको किसका हो गया ग्रे हैट वरफेन
का हो गया अग रेगुलर एक्सप्रेशन पढ़ना
जरूर आप ध्यान दीजिएगा बिना पढ़े मत वो
कीजिएगा इसको जरूर पढ़िए यहां पे आप डंप
करके फाइंड ऑल फाइल्स कंटेनिंग कीवर्ड डंप
एंड एंड विथ जी जड टायर और जिप ठीक है तो
आपको ये वाला जो है इसको भी आप सर्च कर
सकते हैं जैसे
कि मैं यहां पे सर्च
करूंगा तो फाइलम जो डंप करता हू और इससे
एंड करता हूं वो सारे सर्च करके दे देगा
फिलहाल यहां पे कुछ नहीं दे रहा हमें कोई
को टेंशन नहीं है बैकअप वाली फाइंड ऑल
फाइल दैट बिगिन विथ बैकअप पीएचपी टेस्ट
एक्सटी एवरीथिंग टर एवरीथिंग इन ये इज
लिटरल एंड नॉट यूज इन द एनटायर इंजन इस
तरीके से यू कैन गेट द आईडिया फ्रॉम हियर
सर्चिंग फॉर कीवर्ड वन टू विल रिटर्न
डिफरेंट रिजल्ट देन सर्चिंग फॉर कीवर्ड टू
कीवर्ड वन मतलब कीवर्ड वन टू आगे पीछे भी
इसमें देखना है ठीक है ना कुछ इस तरीके
से कुछ इस तरीके से आपको ये भी ध्यान रखना
है इसको सर्च करते टाइम में ठीक
है
सर्च करोगे ना सर्च करोगे तभी तो बीबी
प्रोग्राम वाले मिलेंगे भाई बिना सर्च किए
डायरेक्ट थोड़ी ना मिल जाएंगे यह भी तो
सोचो बिना सर्च किए बिना टाइम दिए कहां से
मिलेंगे आपको वो देखो यह तो मैं आपको बता
रहा हूं कैसे आपको यूज करना है आपको इनमें
से वो चीजें फाइंड करनी है जिनका बग बाउंट
प्रोग्राम चल रहा हो जिनका रिस्पांसिबल
डिस्क्लोजर हो फाइंड कीजिए अगर
रिस्पांसिबल डिस्क्लोजर है तो रिपोर्ट
कीजिए गवर्नमेंट का कोई चीज आपको मिल रहा
है गवर्नमेंट के पर्टिकुलर जो भी आप आपकी
वेबसाइट जहां पे वो रिपोर्ट करने के लिए
बोलते हैं वहां रिपोर्ट कीजिए शर्ट को
रिपोर्ट कर दीजिए अगर गवर्नमेंट की कोई
ऐसी कुछ ऐसी है यू कैन रिपोर्ट टू द शर्ट
ठीक है
[संगीत]
दैट्ची करेंगे तो यू विल गेट अ लॉट ऑफ
थिंग्स लॉट ऑफ काइंड ऑफ वीडियोस एंड
समथिंग लाइक दैट तो आप इस तरीके से मीडिया
में आप देख सकते हैं सर्जिकल वीडियोस कुछ
ऐसे करके यहां पे एएस ऑनलाइन टेस्ट
या यह एटी करके य पर आ रहा है पीएपी तो
बहुत सारी यू विल गेट यहां पर यह
इंस्टिट्यूशन लॉस वीडियोस कंप्लीशन कुछ
ऐसे करके टीटी फाइल य वीडियो यहां प आ
जाएगी य लिस्ट आ जाएगी एंड यहां पर अगर
आपने यह वाली चीज कर दी जैसे एक्सलस वाली
हटा दो एंड यहां पर एमपी4 कर दो एमपी4 तो
यू विल गेट मोर रिजल्ट्स रिलेटेड टू एमपी4
आल्सो तो आपको यह आपको य एमपी4 वीडियो य
मिले य देखो आइसोलेटिंग प कुछ करके ये
फोकस वीडियो पोर्ट सेटअप ये वीडियोस मिल
जाएंगे राइट आईल ऐसे कुछ करके यहां पे
स्टैटिक वीडियोस ड मूवी एसेट्स तो आपको
वीडियोस वाली भी चीज जो है वो मिल जाएंगे
ठीक
है डोंट ट्राई मच ऑफ द थिंग्स मैं य
बोलूंगा आपको बस रिपोर्ट करना है वो
रिपोर्ट कीजिए ट्स इट खत्म ज्यादा दिमाग
मत चलाया कीजिए इन चीजों में कुछ ऐसी
सेंसिटिव चीजें भी आपको मिल सकती है ऐसी
जगह प तो आपको उनसे बच के रहना है ज्यादा
छेर छ नहीं करनी
अब मुझे मान लो यहां पर सर्च करनी है हां
अब एक और चीज आपको बताता हूं एडब्ल्यू
हंटिंग बकेट हंटिंग का वो आप देख लीजिए
ठीक है लेट्स सी इसका नाम है जीएचडीबी ग
हैकिंग डेटाबेस ठीक है आप इस पर आ जाइएगा
जीएसस डीबी पे यहां आ गए आप यहां आ जाइएगा
जी एसडीबी प ऑलरेडी आप आ चुके हैं यहां पे
ये एक ग हैकिंग डेटाबेस जो है वो एक डॉग्स
का लिस्ट है जिसमें जो अपडेटेड डॉग्स है
जो लोग डालते रहते हैं सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चस
हो गए बग बाउटी हंटर्स हो गए ऐसे जो साइबर
सिक्योरिटी डोमेन के वो खुद के डॉक्स आपको
डालते रहते हैं कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग डॉक्स
आपको यहां मिल जाएंगे इसमें हम सर्च कर
लेंगे एडब्ल्यू एस
s3 तो हमें s3 से रिलेटेड जो डॉक्स है वो
सारे डॉग्स यहां पे मिल जाएंगे देखिए यहां
पे ये सारे डॉक्स s3 से रिलेटेड है अब
आपको s3 से रिलेटेड कोई इंफॉर्मेशन बकेट्स
वगैरह फाइंड करनी है तो आप इससे भी फाइंड
कर सकते हैं सिंपल जैसे पहला डॉक यहां पे
आपको मिल रहा है यहां पे इंडेक्स ऑफ लेट्स
गो एंड
सर्च लेट्स गो गो एंड सर्च एंड ये देखिए
इंडेक्स ऑफ बकेट ट्रिप डाटा इंडेक्स ऑफ
बकेट डाउनलोड ऑरेंज एफएस यह देखिए बकेट
लोडिंग यहां पे बहुत सारी बकेट्स आप देखिए
20 एब 48 एबी 2 एबी 2 एब 7 एबी 6 एबी यह
सारे डेटा है बैकअप फाइल्स है यहां पे
बहुत सारी यू कैन गेट दैट इंडेक्स ऑफ
प्रोडक्शन यूके 2018 कुछ है यहां
पे अ
हवे डाटा कुछ है यहां पर यह देखिए हवे
डाटा यह देखि य पर 4 एबी 5
एमबी यह सारे डाटा है यहां पर 10 एमबी 50
एमबी 100 एमबी बहुत सार डटा य प 60 131
एमबी तो यह डाटा है आप इसको डाउनलोड करके
देख सकते हैं इफ यू वांट इ इ एनी ऑफ यूज
कोई यूज का है
तो यहां पर भी अगेन यू विल गेट द बकेट्स
ठीक है तो यहां पर भी आपको बकेट 300 m 400
एब ये
देखो वर्डप्रेस की यहां पे और भी चीजें
हैं फाइल्स वगैरह है उसी तरीके से
यूजर डिटेल तो यहां पे कुछ सैंपल यूजर नेम
पासवर्ड ऐसे करके कुछ दिया हुआ है एडमिन
कुछ किसी ने दिया होगा उसका डिटेल है यहां
पे ए प स्टीमेट क्या है
यह लेट्स ओपन मैं तो खोल दे रहा हूं आप
लोग ऐसे ही मत खोल दीजिएगा थोड़ा ध्यान
दीजिएगा यह देखिए यहां पे कुछ वेबसाइट
डेवलपमेंट प्रोजेक्ट प्रोजेक्ट एंड पेमेंट
प्लान करके यहां पे है ए प का किसी का
यूआई डिजाइन एंड डेवलपमेंट इस तरह से करके
है माइलस्टोन यह सारी चीजें यहां पर दे
रखी है टोटल पेमेंट 3024 यूएसडी होगी हां
यूएसडी 3000 यूएसडी वीडियो रिकॉर्डिंग
वीडियो प्लेइंग एंड इसमें क्या-क्या
फीचर्स है फंक्शनल है वो सारी चीजें
डिटेल्स है माइलस्टोन है सारी चीजें यहां
पे दे रखी है सो इस तरह की चीजें आपको मिल
सकती है कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग मिले तो आप अगर
बक बाउटी प्रोग्राम है तो रिपोर्ट कर सकते
हैं ठीक है हां अगर आप देखिए ना आपको
फाइंड करना है इसमें यू हैव टू फाइंड कि
यह किसी पर्टिकुलर बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम
वाले वेबसाइट से बिलोंग करते हैं किसी
कंपनी से या नहीं करते हैं तो रिपोर्ट
कीजिए अदर वाइज लीव इट ये क्या है भाई
जो सीजी का कुछ रिपोर्ट है यहां पर य आप
देख सकते
हैं एप्लीकेशन टाइटल कांटेक्ट ओ हो हो
हो यह रिपोर्ट है कुछ नाइस
ग्रेट यहां पर कुछ चीजें मिल रही है य पर
अप्रूव लिस्ट लेट्स
सी बनाना रिपब्लिक फर्स्ट विजिट
बहुत सारी लिस्ट मिल जाती है बहुत सी चीज
मिल सकती है अगर कुछ ऐसे देखो कुछ ऐसा
रिजल्ट आपको मिलता है जो आपको लगता है
सेंसिटिव है और किसी बग बाउटी प्रोग्राम
से रिलेटेड है देन यू शुड गो विद ट रिजल्ट
एंड यू शुड रिपोर्ट ठीक है ह पट भी हो
जाएगा अगर आपको लाइक अगर आप किसी किसी हनी
पट में भी आ सकते हो यह भी न रखिएगा थोड़ा
सा इसको थोड़ा ध्यान रखिएगा नहीं तो
दिक्कत हो जाएगा आपके
साथ आएंगे भाई हनी पट पर भी आएंगे टेंशन
मत
लो हा एक्सलस पासवर्ड वाला आप कर सकते हैं
एक्सलस पासवर्ड अगर
कुछ पासवर्ड वाला अभी जो हमने किया था शीट
वन पासवर्ड शीट वन पासवर्ड कुछ मिलता है
तो यू कैन गो फॉर
इट यू कैन सी इफ सम पासवर्ड
इज यूजर नेम पासवर्ड ये
देखिए ये
देखिए ये इंस्टीट्यूट्स है आई
थिंक यस
अलग अलग उसके एंड यह पासवर्ड इसके एक ही
तरह के पासवर्ड है मेंशन है एंड यहां
पर लेट्स कॉपी इट लेट्स सी व्ट इज दिस
यूआरएल यरल देख लेते एक बार व्ट इ दिस
यूआरएल कुछ है भी क्या अच्छा यह तो डोमेन
एक्सपायर हो गया है
व्टक
यहां देख लेते हैं
कॉपी लेट्स डन इट लेट्स ओपन
इट मैक्ड कॉ यूजर लिंक साइड एरर ठीक
[संगीत]
है नेपिया व्ट इसस
नेपिया
यप ओके यह सारे एजिस्ट अभी नहीं कर रहे
हैं बट ठीक है कोई दिक्कत नहीं कुछ फाइल्स
हमें मिल जाती है इस तरीके से यू कैन गेट
द फाइल्स लेट्स गो टू
हियर य आपने ग हैकिंग डेटाबेस का यूज किया
अब आपके पास
google3 से रिलेटेड इंफो फाइंड कर सकते
हैं तो मेरे पास यहां पे मैं यहां ओपन
करता हूं यहां प आपको मैं दिखा देता
हूं सॉरी
लेट मी शो
यू वेर ट वेर र र र यहां तो हमने देख लिया
य हमने देख
लिया लेट्स गो टू
द
बांटी
लेट गो टू गिट अप
डॉक्स लेट गो टू डॉक्स र यह डॉक्स है
हमारे एंड हां अब यहां पर हम एक काम करते
हैं यहां पर हम क्या करते हैं यहां पर गल
डॉक्स गल
डॉक्स गल डॉक्स
फॉर एडब ए3 बकेट्स य हमने किया अब य पर हम
की लिस्ट मिल जाएगी एंड आप ऐसे डॉक्स को
भी यूज कर सकते हैं ठीक है इस तरीके से भी
आप यूज कर सकते हैं जैसे मैंने एक यह
google3 एक्सप्लोरर के ये अलग-अलग कंपनीज
की ये देखिए यहां पे ए3 एक्सप्लोर मिल रहा
है यहां प मुझे कुछ बकेट्स मिल रहे है
यहां पे 20 के पांच देख लेते हैं 20 के
पांच में क्या है थर्ड में क्या है एंड वी
गॉट इट हियर वी गॉट सम फाइल्स हियर 91 केब
91 केब ये सारे 91 केब के हैं इस तरीके से
वी कैन गेट सम थिंग्स एंड यहां पे डटा
ब्राउजर ड
html4 एब की कोई फाइल है पार्ट 0z कोई
फाइल है कोई 4 एब की वी कैन गेट समथिंग इन
टू
इट सो इफ वी कैन एक्सट्रैक्ट इट लेट्स
सी एक्सट्रैक्ट ऑल
एक्सट्रैक्ट एंड व्हाट इज देयर
ओके नथिंग मच कुछ
ये ज्यादा चीजों को ओपन नहीं करेंगे
ज्यादा दिमाग नहीं लगाएंगे ठीक है तो इस
तरीके से आप
यूज कर सकते हैं यहां पे उसके बाद यहां पे
index.htm यह वाली चीज यूज कर सकते हैं
amazon2 ज इंजेक्स इंडेक्स नेशनल हेल्प
नेशनल हेल्प यहां से कुछ मिलेगा
क्या लेट्स
सी ओवरऑल आपको करना क्या है यह आपको समझ
में आ रहा है कोई मुझे समरा इज करके बताओ
जल्दी से यह आपको कुछ डिटेल्स मिल गए यहां
पे रेबल बक रिपो सी फाइल यहां पे यह
फाइल्स कुछ मिली यहां पे अभी आप में से
कोई एक बताओ ओवरऑल करना क्या है ओवरऑल
क्या करना है आपको समझ में आ रहा है इसमें
सिंपल सा क्या करना
है इस एडब्ल्यू के लिए देखिए मैं आपको
सिंपल सा फंडा बता देता
हूं सिंपल सा फंडा क्या है यह यूज़ किया
चौथा हमने अ यूज्ड
[संगीत]
लीक्ड बकेट्स
पाच
यूज्ड ग्रे हैट ग्रे हैट वर
फेयर वेब
पोर्टल टू फाइंड लीक्ड बकेट्स ठीक है हमने
यह यूज किया एस3 स्कैनर यूज किया हमने गिट
हब का यूज किया हमने जी एसडीबी का यूज
किया हमने एड्स सीआई का देखा कैसे किस
तरीके से आपको इंटरेक्ट करना है किस तरीके
से चीजों एक्सेस करना है अगर कोई चीज आपको
मिल जा कोई भी एडब्ल्यू एस का बकेट मिल जा
रहा है तो उसको कैसे आपको एक्सेस करके
देखना है अगर आप एक्सेस कर पा रहे हो कि
नहीं कर पा रहे हो ओनली रीड एक्सेस होगा
तो आपको रीड एक्सेस प फिर वो चीज नहीं काम
करेगी आपको राइट और डिलीट का मतलब राइट
वाला एक्सेस होना चाहिए आप उसको उसमें
कॉपी कर कर पाओ कोई चीज डिलीट कर पाओ कोई
चीज देन दैट वुड बी मच इंटरेस्टिंग
राइट ओके चलिए यहां पर देखते हैं अमेजिंग
कंटेंट आई हैव एवर सीन फ्रॉम योर
प्लेलिस्ट सर आई हैव फाउंड टू बक्स बाय
जस्ट सीइंग योर प्लेलिस्ट फ्रॉम सेंसिटिव
इंफो वन इज एक्सेप्टेड एंड वन इज इन ट्रैग
स्टेट थैंक्स एंड लव फ्रॉम पाकिस्तान अ
थैंक यू सो मच अ ब्रदर एंड काफी अच्छा लगा
अगर आपने प्लेलिस्ट देख के बग फाइंड किए
एंड दैट इज वैलिड एंड आपने आपका वो ट्रैग
हुआ है आई एम वेरी प्राउड मुझे काफी अच्छा
लग रहा है यह सुनके एंड जब आपका फाइनल जब
आपको बाउटी मिल जाए तो प्लीज डोंट फॉरगेट
टू टैग डेनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी
भी सकते हैं आई विल पोस्ट ट ओके ताकि पता
चले
ओके यस हमें क्या करना है सिंपली हमें
हमारा मेन मोटिव क्या है
मोटिव मोटिव क्या है टू फाइंड लीक्ड और
मिस
कन्फर्स एस3
बकेट एस3 बकेट
फ्रॉम ऑल ओवर
इंटरनेट फॉर अ फॉर अ पाटी फॉर अ पर्टिकुलर
टारगेट फॉर पर्टिकुलर टारगेट हमें यह
निकालना है तो हमें लेजी का हमने देखा
क्या कर रहे थे हम ले में सेम एक टारगेट
के लिए हम हंट कर रहे थे सिंपल सा फंडा एक
टारगेट के लिए हमने क्या किया हंट किया
ठीक है किस तरीके से किया देखो मैं यहां
पर एी क्यूट कर देता हूं यह डिस्कनेक्ट हो
जाता है चलो अच्छा ही है यहां पर मैं यहां
प जूम इन कर ले यहां पे हमने एक टारगेट के
लिए किया क्या किया
सीडी लेज s3 में गए थे हम यहां पे एंड
यहां हमने इसको एग्जीक्यूट कर दिया रूबी
से रूबी लेजी s3 आबी और यहां हम अपने
टारगेट का यहां पे दे देते हैं जो भी
लिस्ट में हमारा टारगेट है उस पर्टिकुलर
कीवर्ड के लिए वो हंट करना शुरू कर देता
है ट्स इट हम यहां पे कोई भी टारगेट मेंशन
कर देते हैं कोई भी टारगेट मेंशन कर दो
भाई जैसे कि हमारा टारगेट हम दे देते हैं
दे दिया और एंटर कर दिया अब ये स्टार्ट
करेगा
facebook.com अ बट यू विल नॉट फाइंड
एनीथिंग हियर आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे
facebooksignup.in इस हंट कर सकते अलग अलग
चीजों प यू कैन गो एंड यू कैन हंट ठीक है
तो एक तो आपने यह काम कर दिया उसके बाद आप
ए3 स्कनर का यूज कर ले रहे हैं भैया एस
स्कनर में आपने बकेट की पूरी लिस्ट डाली
उसमें से आप फाइंड करने की कोशिश कर रहे
पर्टिकुलर चीज के लिए यह चीज कर दी उसके
बाद आप क्या कर सकते
हैं
फाइंड देखो फाइंड ऑल द
पॉसिबल फाइंड ऑल द पॉसिबल सब डोमेन वड
लिस्ट वर्ड लिस्ट एंड पास इट ऑन s3
स्कनर अब वर्ड लिस्ट के आपके पास पूरी
लिस्ट होगी ना वर्ड लिस्ट वाली तो बहुत
मजा आएगा आपके पास अगर सब डोमेन का वर्ड
लिस्ट होगा तो इससे क्या होगा इससे आपका
आपको क्या होगा इससे होगा क्या जैसे आप सब
डोमेन की लिस्ट को जब आप पास आउट करेंगे
जैसे आपने क्या किया एक पर्टिकुलर टारगेट
के लिए पास आउट कर रहे हो ना लेज s3 से यह
वाली यह वाली एक पर्टिकुलर टारगेट के लिए
आप कर रहे हो ये 4043 आरहा है अब इसमें
मैं सब डोमेंस की लिस्ट डाल दूंगा मान लो
तो सब डोमस की लिस्ट जब आप डालोगे तो वो
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग हो जाएगा उसमें जैसे कि
मैं यहां पे कॉपी अ वो कर रहा हूं मैं
यहां पे एलएस कर रहा हूं अभी यहां पे क्या
है कॉमन बकेट प्रीफिक्सेस है ना कैट कॉमन
बकेट प्रीफिक्सेस इसमें ये सारे
प्रीफिक्सेस
हैं ये सारी आपको प्रीफिक्सेस मिल रहे हैं
यहां पे अब मैं इसमें सब डोमेन वाली चीज
सब डोमेन वाली जो प्रीफिक्स है ना वो डाल
देता हूं चलो अब एक काम करते हैं कैसे
करते हैं सब डोमिनल प्रीफिक्स कैसे
डालेंगे देखिए यहां पे मेरे पास एक लिस्ट
मैं यहां पे यहां पे मैं एक वो निकाल लेता
हूं जैसे कि कि क्या बोलते हैं उसको
वर्डलिस्ट निकाल लेता हूं तो वर्डलिस्ट
में यहां से उठा लेता हूं मेरे पास एक
वर्डलिस्ट पड़ी
है लेट्स
सी जस्ट वेट वड लिस्ट आप कहीं से भी ले
सकते हैं सेक लिस्ट से उठा सकते हैं सब
डोमेन वाली या एसेट नोट से उठा सकते हैं
जो मैंने आपको बताया हुआ था बट मेरे पास
एक अभी है मैं वहां से एक ले लेता हूं
जहां से आप चाहे मर्जी आप वहां से उठाइए
ठीक है सब डोमेन वाली तो मेरे पास एक
वर्डलिस्ट वाली है पे मैं यहां से
वर्डलिस्ट निकाल लेता
हूं 10000 वाली पॉपुलर 10000 वाली जो
वर्डलिस्ट है ना ये वाली निकाल लेते हैं
10000 वाली इसको निकाल लिया हमने यहां
पे चलिए तो ये वर्ड लिस्ट की ये पूरी आपकी
लिस्ट आ जाएगी सब डोमेन वाली इसको मैंने
यहां पे ऑलरेडी शायद निकाल के रखा हुआ है
मेरे ख्याल से अ मेरे यहां पे एलएस करता
हूं मैं यहां पे आई थिंक मेरे पास होगा
शायद यस बिट क्वक वर्डलिस्ट .
txt.gz उसको डालने वाला हूं कहां पे डालने
वाला हूं भैया हमारे लेज s3 के अंदर में
तो कैसे हम डाल लेंगे बहुत सिंपल सा चीज
है क्या करेंगे बिट क्वक वाली वर्ड लिस्ट
को डाल देंगे तो यहां पे हम कर देते
हैं
कैट बिटक वर्ड लिस्ट एंड लेज s3 में चल
जाते हैं एक बार सीडी लेज s3 यहां पे मैं
f11 कर देता हूं एलस कर देते हैं कॉमन
बकेट प्रीफिक्सेस t एकटी ठीक है भैया इसी
में डालनी है सिंपल सा फंडा है सेम नाम
होना चाहिए नाम आपको चेंज नहीं करना है
क्योंकि टूल में उसी तरीके का सेम नेम यूज
हुआ होगा नेम चेंज करेंगे आपका फिर टूल
सही से काम करेगा नहीं दैट्ची है तो चलिए
अब यहां पे कर देते हैं सीपी
[संगीत]
अ कैट एंड कैट में क्या करते हैं रूट के
अंदर में क्या था हमारा अ बिट क्वार वर्ड
लिस्ट यहां पे तो ये हमने कर दिया और इसको
हमें रीड करना है और इसके रीड करने के बाद
इसके आउटपुट को हमें डबल कोट ये डबल
लाइक हमने यहां पर स्टडी आउट जो किया है
यह हमने दो बार इसलिए किया है ताकि अपेंड
हो यह रिप्लेस ना कर दे ठीक है उसके अंदर
की फाइल्स को कॉमन बकेट वाली को तो हम
यहां पे कॉमन बकेट प्रिक्ड कर देते हैं और
एंटर कर देते हैं नाउ अब हम कॉमन बकेट को
चेक करते हैं कि इसमें कितनी फाइल्स है तो
यह सारी फाइल्स आ चुकी है यह देखिए सारी
पूरी वर्डलिस्ट आ गई है पूरी यह पहले 19
पहले कितना था
यह पहले बहुत कम था ये अब करते हैं कैट
कॉमन वर्डलिस्ट वाली तो अब यहां पर बहुत
सारी फाइल हो जाती है यहां पे 1016 हो
जाती है ये 1016 और ओरिजिनल फाइल में
कितनी एंट्रीज है यह भी आपको दिखा देता
हूं ताकि आपको लगे कि यहां कॉपी हुआ है
लेजी
s3 गेट
अप ओरिजिनल जो इनकी बकेट वाली फाइल है
इसमें कितनी
है 196 है ओनली 196 तो अब हमारे पास 10000
कुछ आ चुके हैं अब मैं यहां पे इसका यूज
करूंगा लेज s3 के अंदर में तो अब मैं यहां
पे टूल को रन करूंगा बहुत सिंपली यहां पे
रूबी कमांड डालूंगा एंड
facebook's कार्ट किसी के लिए भी जा सकते
हैं तो चलिए लेंस कार्ट के लिए चलते हैं
और एंटर कर देते हैं अब जब हम एंटर करेंगे
तो अब हमें जो बकेट्स लिस्ट जो ये फेच कर
रहा है जो दे रहा है देखो यहां पे 46000 4
64202 आइटम्स इतने आइटम्स पे यह ट्राई
करेगा सर्च करेगा बकेट्स के लिए अगर कोई
बकेट 200 200 रिस्पांस के साथ आता है तो
मतलब आप एक्सेस कर सकते हैं फिर आप एक्सेस
करके देखिए फिर एडब्ल्यू एस कमांड लाइन का
ंटर सीआई का यूज कीजिए देखिए कि उसको क्या
परमिशन है क्या-क्या चीजें आप कर सकते हैं
तो फिर आप रिपोर्ट कर सकते हैं पर्टिकुलर
अपने टारगेट के लिए ठीक है ये समझ में आ
गया या या या
राइट अपना नाम बता दीजिए
किसी और ने रिपोर्ट कर दिया आपने तो फाइंड
किया उसको वो डुप्लीकेट निकल गई कोई टेंशन
नहीं है मूव ऑन आगे बढ़ आपको वैलिड बग भी
मिलेगा इस बात की फुल गारंटी मैं आपको
देता हूं एंड इसके पहले भी एक बंदे ने
मुझे लिंकन पर मैसेज किया था कि आई गट अ
बग मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं लेट मी शो
यू ताकि आपको लगे कि
यस लेट्स
सी
यह देखिए मुझे एक मैसेज आया था आपको मैं
दिखा देता हूं थैंक यू आई फाउंड हिरोक
एपीआई की एंड रिपोर्टेड बिकॉज ऑफ योर
लेक्चर ऑन
को आपको अगर मैं कुछ पढ़ा रहा हूं सिखा
रहा हूं तो बस अगर रिजल्ट आ रहा है और फिर
क्या चाहिए कुछ नहीं चाहिए लव यू टू ब्रदर
फ्रॉम
इंडिया आई डोंट नो आपको दिखा होगा कि नहीं
बट ठीक है
अ चलिए तो यह अपना काम कर रहा है तो हमें
क्या करना है सिंपली अ जैसे कि मैंने आपको
बताया क्या करना है जितने पॉसिबल सब डोमस
हैं आप उसको फाइंड कर लीजिए पर्टिकुलर सब
डोमेन वर्डलिस्ट जो है और उसको पास आउट
कीजिए पास इट ऑन ए3 स्कैनर या फिर और और
लेजी ए3 ठीक है इस पर पास आउट कीजिए
ओके कोई बात नहीं बग नहीं मिला कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है बग मिलना इज नॉट कि आपको बग
मिलेगा तभी आपको आता है ऐसा कुछ नहीं है
बग बाउंट में यही तो खासियत है कि बग ना
भी मिले आपको आती है चीज आप ट्राई करते
रहो एक दिन मिलेगी इतनी मैं गारंटी दे
सकता हूं आपको ठीक है तो टेंशन नहीं लेना
तो इस करना है मैनुअल न्यूमरेशन मैनुअल
एन्यूमरेशन करना है ग्रेट वॉर फेयर का
googleupdate.exe एपीआई की वहां भी
एडब्ल्यू एस की आपको एडब्ल्यू एस सीक्रेट
एडब्ल्यू एस यूजर आईडी मिल जाएगी तो फिर
आप वही काम कीजिए जो यहां पर मिल रही है
सिंपल सी चीज है फंडा सिंपल फंडा है बस हो
गया और कुछ नहीं करना है आपको तो गिट अप
पे भी आप रिकॉन करके ये काम कर सकते हैं
एपीआई इसके लिए फाइंड करके हं करके कर
सकते हैं
राइट बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया बहुत
बढ़िया तो यह अपना काम कर रहा है क्योंकि
ये स्कैनिंग करता रहेगा बहुत लंबी लिस्ट
है हमारे पास तो स्कैनिंग करता रहेगा हर
एक चीज के लिए एंड तना टाइम लेगा इसको
चलते देना है कोई टेंशन नहीं है कुछ अगर
मिलता है इंटरेस्टिंग तो इससे बढ़िया तो
क्या ही हो सकता है राइट तो इट्स डूइंग
इट्स वर्क एंड व्हेन एवर रिजल्ट विल गेट
इट विल गेट द रिजल्ट इट विल शो यू हियर
याद रखिएगा एक चीज मैंने आपको पहले ही बोल
दिया है वीडियो स्टार्ट होने से पहले ही
कि आप लोगों का नेक्स्ट क्लास तभी होगा 15
क्लास जब आप लोग टास्क कीजिएगा और अपने जो
भी रिपोर्ट टास्क नहीं भी है कोई मान
लीजिए आपका कोई रिपोर्ट आपने जो काम किया
है जो भी आप हंटिंग कर रहे हो उसको एक
उसकी फोटो ले लो या स्क्रीनशॉट ले लो या
पीडीएफ बना लो या डॉक फाइल में डाल दो
एंड थैंक यू सो मच फॉर जॉइनिंग द सेशन
नेक्स्ट सेशन में जरूर आइए एडब्ल्यू एस3
बकेट मिस कंफिट आई होप आप इसको इसको आप
रिवाइज करेंगे जितना रिवा याद रखिएगा जो
मैं आपको बता रहा हूं अगर आपने उसको
रिवाइज नहीं किया तो कोई फायदा नहीं है
आपको जो गैप मिल रहा है दो दिन तीन दिन जो
भी गैप मिल रहा है ना उस गैप को
अपॉर्चुनिटी की तरह लीजिए और उसमें पूरा
प्रैक्टिस कीजिए प्रीवियस जितना है
प्रैक्टिस करते रहिए करते रहिए और जब तक
मैं आगे ना बढूं आपको आगे अभी नहीं बढ़ना
है बस अभी बिगनर लेवल पे आपको मेरे
साथ-साथ ही चलना है मैं जैसे-जैसे चल रहा
हूं वैसे-वैसे चलिए आपको मजा आएगा अभी
जितना कुछ बता दिया उतना में बहुत कुछ आप
कर सकते हो अभी बहुत कुछ फाइंड कर सकते हो
फाइंड करने के लिए बहुत सारी चीजें हैं
जितना टाइम दोगे उतनी चीजें फाइंड करोगे
इतना ही मैं बोलूंगा तो बस उतना उतनी
फाइंड करने फाइंड करने की कोशिश कीजिए हंट
कीजिए एक्सप्लोर कीजिए एंड ट्राई टू अ गेट
सम वैलिड बक्स ठीक
है चलिए
बढ़िया
ओके एडब सीआ इंस्टॉल कर लेंगे आप एक्सेस
कर पाएंगे सारी चीजें अगर आप बकेट को रीड
राइट डिलीट कर सकते हैं कर पा रहे हैं तो
आप उसको रिपोर्ट जरूर कीजिए ब बकेट में
कोई सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन है आप रिपोर्ट कर
सकते हैं आप उसको एड ले 3 ले s3 s3 स्कनर
से
google3
[संगीत]
टूल्स यह वाली मैंने आपको बताई थी यह वाली
यूआरएल गेट रिपोजिटरी यहां पर सारे टूल्स
जो आप यूज कर सकते हैं वो यहां पर मिल
जाएंगे मैं आपको यहां पर यह दे देता
हूं यह हमारा सेशन कहां
गया यह कैंसिल हो गया था क्या हमारा सेशन
वाला
पेज
सॉरी
ओके तो मैं यहां पर चैट में दे देता हूं
सेशन वाला पेज ही क्लोज हो गया था मेरे
ख्याल
से हा तो आईम गिविंग दिस इन द चैट प्लीज
सी
दिस चलिए मैंने य पर यह जो यूआरएल है यह
दे दिया चैट
में आप इसको देख सकते हैं ठीक है एंड ट्स
इट गाइस आज के सेशन के
लिए स्क्रीनशॉट लेना है नोटपैड का ठीक है
मैं नोटपैड ओपन कर लेता हूं मैं इसको
थोड़ा छोटा कर देता हूं ताकि आपको दिख जाए
पूरा एक बार में
ही ठीक है ये स्क्रीनशॉट ले लीजिए नोटपैड
का अगर लेना है तो अ एंड ट्राई टू हंट ओके
टू फाइंड लीक ऑ मिस कंफिल बकेट फ्रॉम ल
ओवर द इंटरनेट फॉर अ पर्टिकुलर टारगेट
टारगेट के लिए आपको पता ही है लेज s3 यूज़
कर सकते हैं s3 स्कैनर से पूरा स्कैन मार
सकते हैं और भी बहुत सारे टूल्स उसको यूज़
किए ठीक है थैंक यू सो मच गाइ अ फॉर टुडेज
सेशन हमें सोशल मीडिया प्लेटफॉर्म पे फॉलो
कर लीजिएगा एड ऐप है डिस अकेडमी इंस्टॉल
कर लीजिएगा उसपे बहुत सही इंटरेस्टिंग
स्प्स है आपको मिल जाएंगी कोर्सेस है मिल
जाएंगी एंड हमारा एक एथिकल हैकिंग का
कोर्स है जिसको आप ए हैप ऐप पे ही जाके
देख के और आप उसमें इनरोल भी कर सकते हैं
बहुत कुछ सीख सकते हैं एंड दैट्ची है तो
आज के लिए बस इतना ही गाइज थैंक यू सो मच
फॉर जॉइनिंग नेक्स्ट सेशन में फिर से
आइएगा और इस सेशन को शेयर करना मत भूलिए
कुछ भी अगर आपने वैल्यू गेन किया इस सेशन
से कुछ सीखा है इस बग बांटी की क्लासेस से
तो इस क्लासेस को शेयर कीजिए whatsapp's